She's saying him there and we go live
and then things are crackling and then
people are talking and
everybody's listening.
What the fuck?
No,
no one's Thomas.
What the sign?
We could just do it.
All right.
So right now we're starting right now.
That's for a second.
Sorry.
Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the fleshlight.
And if you go to Joe Rogan duct to net
and click on the link for the flashlight
and then use the codename Rogan,
you will save yourself 15% off.
So you will not just shoot your little
loads that you're trying to get rid of.
You'll save yourself
a little bit of money.
I used mine the other day,
they'd like to remember,
I told him,
you said Tim for the podcast.
I just was sitting in my
man cave and I was like,
I didn't want to fuck my flashlight.
Wow.
And it just,
I looked at it and it was
just sitting there like,
what are you doing?
What are you doing?
Like it was
like,
you know,
that's the thing,
when you take it on like the
road with you for a weekend,
you feel like it's a whore.
Like when you take it on the road with you
and just fuck it,
like a Chechen hoard the
bottom of a coal mine.
That was a great analogy.
It's a,
it's a little too good.
Well,
I don't think women are
very comfortable with it.
It's a little too effective.
And by the way,
this is just the beginning.
I mean,
technology's going to improve,
right?
200 years ago we didn't have a
car and now we have a flashlight.
What would it be?
The technology of flashlight.
Do you think it's a robot fuck doll?
Yeah,
for sure.
Something that like acts like
the hottest porn star alive,
but only exists to fuck.
You know,
like you shut it off,
but when you turn it on it looks
like a person and it wants to fuck.
I mean,
it's really creepy to us,
but we have to assume that we are,
we're not a perfect being.
The human beings not perfect.
Right?
It's not at all.
It's not done being involved.
It's just a step along the way.
Just like monkeys were step along the way.
Just like turtles are
a step along the way.
We're this,
this thing is still trying
to advance and improve.
Right.
So you got to accept the fact that
that's a part of the equation.
Part of the equation.
We've got duplicate,
I forgot this analogy was about Jackie.
We're going to duplicate bodies,
we're going to duplicate
them and fuck them.
I need,
I just sometimes you don't want all the
extra hassle that comes with dealing
with a person.
You know,
just want to be able to get rid of some
loads and if you could have like a fake
person like that can even make out
with you and stuff like a fake person.
It's creepy though cause the
idea is like well what is that?
This is blade runner
and he's just fucking,
is this like some sort of human slavery?
Are you,
do you really wish you had a real person?
What if this inspires people
to actually get real slaves?
You know,
and then they don't do to have that.
That guy had that girl trapped
under his bed and he was married.
He made her sleep under his bed.
Have you ever seen that thing?
Yeah.
Where was that?
Where the,
where the fuck was that?
She was like 18.
She could like go to the mall to me,
Shit.
And then she under the bed and they
just fucking did crazy shit to her.
I would that it's that.
It's that Stockholm Syndrome.
Is that right?
Where you believe that your
capture is helping you out?
So I've been in relationships like that.
The robot Fucker,
I'll start off with a mouth and
then like as technology gets better,
the mouth,
it gets smaller and smaller and smaller
and they know the beat and no mouth.
Why would you say that?
Because she taught a big bright,
not like blowjobs through some issues.
Anyway,
we're also brought to you by [inaudible]
dot com makers of Alpha brain,
Trintech,
immune shroom,
tech sport,
and a new mood.
All these things are nootropics and uh,
the other ones are performance
enhancing substances.
What's the five HTP one?
It's whole new moon.
I swear by that 100% and you're talking
to me about a guy that has obsessive
compulsive and anxiety issues.
I swear by that.
When I start spiraling I go
for that instead of Xanax.
And that is a bold fucking statement.
Well it's legit man.
What it does is it boosts your
brain's ability to make serotonin.
It gives you the building
blocks are serotonin and l
Tryptophan converts to five
HTP,
so that's in there as well.
So it's gone a sort of a
time release effect to it.
It's,
it's a very effective supplement and it's,
it's not something you have
to worry about if you're,
if you're fascinated by any of this stuff.
But there are,
what they are is called nootropics.
NOOTROPIC is n o t r o p,
I c and Google that and read
some information because
it's a very controversial
subject.
I bought,
I believe in nootropics.
I'm a big believer in vitamins and
supplements and eating healthy and uh,
I have always been interested in
taking the best fuel for my body.
And my belief,
the best fuel for your
brain has been mapped out.
It's,
they're called nootropics.
And Alpha brain is the best combination
of these nootropics that we know how to
make.
What's the highest class ingredients?
And we also make sure that there is a
100% money back guarantee on your first
order of 30.
We need like a cough button or some shit.
I didn't turn down my volume.
We
see I have a button.
You'll see.
I have like a button though.
So if I have to sneeze or anything,
am I clear my throat?
I have a button.
We should probably install those things,
right?
We should just have a
signal like you point to me.
That's a really good idea.
You just sneezed.
Whatever the fuck.
It's a big deal.
Um,
anyway,
I go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for Alpha brain,
enter in the code named Rogan and you
can save yourself 10% off any and all
orders.
And what I was saying earlier,
we have a hundred percent money back
guarantee on the order of a first order of
30 pills.
So when you take something,
if you try and you're like,
this is not worth it.
This is bullshit.
You don't even have to return the product.
It's a hundred percent
money back guarantee.
We're trying to make it as fair as
possible while selling you stuff that I
absolutely believe in.
All right.
Hey,
can I get some of that
shroom tech from you?
Okay.
A lot of shit for you.
Nice.
That's an Alpha brain to it.
Mix it up with the [inaudible].
We're celebrating Joe Rogan.
Powerful Bird Chrysler's here,
ladies and gentleman strapped the fucking
hotel experience.
[inaudible] Joe Rogan
podcast by night all day.
Powerful Bert Kreischer.
I'm planning mine.
I'm going to have it.
I'm going to try that and match and
Nick Diaz on the biggest stage possible,
whether it be Letterman,
like just slide it in,
but I want to make it unclear.
I want to make it awkward.
Hey,
Nick Diaz at night.
I mean,
nevermind.
Don't kid
Nick Diaz at night,
man.
Fucking up Kll.
Sonin Chelsea,
that dude is on motherfucker.
I fucking that guys.
I've never been sold to an entity.
Yeah.
He could leave me into war.
It was a fascinating
dude.
He was really,
he's a fascinating guy.
You know what I really,
when it was really intense when he was
talking about how he was willing to fight
him in Brazil.
Yes.
And that he knew that even if he beat
him in Brazil in front of 80,000 people,
like they were going to want his head.
What did he say about the Brazilians?
Well,
you know what I mean?
He said a lot of shit.
He's,
he's insulted.
Noguera who's,
uh,
you know,
um,
who's the Anderson Silva's Jujitsu
trainer and a famous mixed martial arts
fighter or former pride champion
and one of the all time greats.
It's like,
it would be like insulting Muhammad
Ali or something along those lines.
Or insulting.
No,
I wouldn't say Mohammad Ali,
sugar ray Leonard or something.
You know,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
yeah,
cause he's not like a political
figure during your boundary.
So Neil's joke about my was very fox.
No.
How's my favorite watching Michael J.
Fox on a new conference about
Parkinson's and this motherfucker.
I'll shake the chip
out,
shake the chimp.
Mom is trying to catch up,
but he's like,
I got you mom.
It was a genius.
He was so fucking funny,
mother fucker.
So anyway,
back to on it.
It's so funny.
He go,
Brian,
um,
she'll sign in a,
you know,
since he insulted
Minotauro Nogueira who I,
like I said,
it's a great champion and you know,
uh,
in,
in Brazil,
he's like a,
he's a fucking hero,
you know,
insulted his Jujitsu and is just,
there was a lot of,
lot of,
lot of negative things to be said about
Brazilians and so they fog and aide him
and people don't realize how like
Nationalistic Brazilians are.
Man,
I got that from that
podcast that I was like,
they'd take it to the next level.
I've never been in a crowd that so
nationalistic that was so wanted the,
the Brazilian fighters to win and fucking
hated when the foreign fighters want.
Really?
Yeah.
Only one foreign fighter one.
Mike Kyle was the only guy won that night.
And there were some fucking scar wraps.
I'll tell you the,
the,
the energy and the crowd is so intense.
They love fighting in Brazil.
They fucking love it man.
But very respectful people.
Very nice people.
Very friendly.
You know,
it's not like there's a bunch of thugs
going around like everywhere you go
people are pretty chilled and laid back.
It's a beautiful country and I like to
go buy grain does not going to probably
never going to happen.
You could go with me.
You want to go with me fucking in.
Okay.
I'm done.
Why do you think it's not going to happen?
You travel like every fucking
week or about to go to Scotland.
This is UFC in Brazil and June.
You with me?
All right.
If it fits in my fucking schedule,
my schedule is chaotic.
I'm in.
I'd love to do that.
I don't want to get to fucking
Brazil a while that would get,
you know what?
It's crazy man.
When you just look out over the ocean,
like their view that they have like,
like,
especially in Rio,
it's like I'm so,
they're like so connected to nature.
You know what I mean?
Like they're completely
connected to nature.
I mean,
you look at uh,
how Rio is with the favelas and the
hills and the city at the bottom and the
ocean's right there and
the way you look at it,
it's like,
man,
they're constantly reminded by nature.
You know,
that's something that a lot of
places in America just don't have.
New York doesn't really have that.
You see mostly buildings see
mostly shift that we made.
There's something about being in the
presence of something like mountains and
ocean where it just makes it go shit.
Or even just like wind,
like I went to the top of Mount Washington
and the winds were like 110 miles an
hour and you were up
there and you literally,
I met my heart,
sunk out of my asshole.
I was like,
I could be lifted off his mountain by God.
Just see a Bert to,
could you fucking imagine that's happened
before people had been taken off the
sides of cliffs?
Fuck yes.
Yeah,
they have cool dude.
Cars get tripped over by wind that,
oh wait,
hold on.
So we selling me when I'm driving on the
street and I feel my car getting pushed
by wind.
It's totally possible.
There are cars that have,
cause I always go,
it'll never happen in and huge storms.
Of course I sauce hurricanes.
Yeah.
Well you know in Dallas,
the last tornado man,
they were doers,
semis that were flying in the air.
You didn't see that.
No,
I didn't.
Oh my God,
dude,
that was just this year,
this year in Dallas.
Have you seen it?
Pull up the video,
man.
You've got to show it to them because
it's just so have a video of a hard to
look at it.
It's just you to try to wrap your mind
around something that could take a
Samurai and floated in the air.
Something that you can't see.
An 18 wheeler truck.
It's invisible and it's floating this
fucking semi in the air and the only
reason why it's visible at all,
it's because it's got a swarm
of shit that it's carrying.
It's circling around.
It's got a swarm of shit inside of it.
Fuck God.
Damn it.
That's scary.
What do you do in that situation?
You get pulled up in the wind.
Did you,
is there anything scary then
seeing that funnel cloud,
just knowing there's nothing that
can stop it and you and that,
but that thought where you go,
there's no way this is going to get me.
Look at that dude.
He's flying through the air.
Those can you see that semis
several.
It's grow twirling around in the sky
and then dropping down from at least 50
feet high down into the ground.
You look at that to look at that.
Look at that.
Don had comes bang lands,
lands on the top of mind.
Semis,
dude.
Uh,
certainly we have to say 18 wheelers,
man on the Saas side of Dallas.
Still within parts of it,
like three of them.
It's juggling semis.
Those are light poles.
Those are light poles that are
standing up in the semis were like
Holy Dallas.
Look at that fucking thing,
man.
Area around,
uh,
the Mesquite area just to
the west of mosquitoes.
It's so weird that we're so like so
nonchalant about these things about
tornadoes and living in the,
just even the remote possibility
that a tornado might hate your area.
Like shitting.
You factor that in to
where you fucking live.
Everything you do,
that should be factored.
You should have definite
escape plans into a seller.
Like you shouldn't just be like,
well,
if it comes,
let's just hope.
Did you ever see that Joplin Missouri
footage where they showed the before and
after,
I believe it was Joplin,
Missouri,
it was a town that was literally erased,
literally erased the Tornado's coming.
It's scary.
Scary thing is they can come
in the middle of the night,
man,
they can come in the middle of the night.
So you have to have like tornado warnings,
so someone's gotta be paying attention
and they got a blow horns and then you've
got to get it in your basement while the
monster made out a wind rips your house
apart.
Like,
dude,
they had entire communities just vanished.
They completely vanished
down to the foundation.
It's like,
if that was a wind that was a,
a werewolf that was doing that.
You know what I'm saying?
A bad wolf.
The once a huff and puff
and blow your house down,
you'd be like,
we gotta kill that fucking thing.
We've got to get away from where it lives.
We can't,
you know,
but instead of it being
aware of scape plan,
it's a wind monster.
And we just sort of accept it.
And they,
you live,
you live in the path
of a fucking werewolf.
It's a wind monster,
man.
It's a god.
It's Thor.
You know,
it's ripping houses a pie.
It's a god.
I mean,
no wonder why is storms.
You know,
when,
when you know people were savages,
they thought it was the anger of the gods.
You know?
No wonder why.
Could you imagine?
You don't know where.
It's still something like Katrina,
where you don't know when it's coming.
You both,
maybe it is,
maybe it's a reaction.
Maybe it's a reaction to
what's being disrespectful.
Well,
it's maybe reaction
just to the biological,
the sheer size of the,
the biological entities of the human race.
You know,
the massive amount of waste that we put
out and if that makes it global warming
and if that really does pick
up the intensity of storms,
I know all that Shit's debated.
I don't know if that's true or not.
Whether or not,
I mean,
people have tried to make that
connection between human beings,
global warming and the
acceleration of these big storms,
but I don't know where
the status of that is,
so I don't want to speak to that,
but it's negative energy all collected.
But what,
how,
where would it be if that's,
if we found out it was true that we
found out that once people get to certain
fever pitch,
you know,
the earth just has a,
a response of these big gusts of wind
monsters to sorta like shut everybody the
fuck up.
Why is it so fucking warm over here?
If we were all hippies and
it just be sunny every day
where sunny and beautiful.
Did you imagine that?
That's what it is.
It's like God's death squad is a tornado
is God just sends them down every now
and then,
please get these cuffs off my planet.
And you're just here,
Jo Cox are,
it's just a thing where you
know God created people,
but people just figured out how to
get way too good at some shit way too
quickly.
And it's the race between it nature
trying to squash us and US trying to
transcend being human.
I feel fucking bizarre concept.
It's the race.
It's the race right now.
That's the rice.
It's between us coming up with some
sort of technology that lists us,
lifts us out of our monkey existence or
the to or swallowing us up in a super
volcano.
Fuck.
That's some good champagne.
It was a great champagne.
That's fucking new.
Celebrating.
They're celebrating.
Hold on,
hold on.
Let's wrap this up because I'm a little,
my mind's a little fucking blown.
Okay.
That fucking concept is
like is it was bizarre.
The fucking God is just,
it's that ridiculous.
Really.
It's just weather.
Nope.
All right,
so the reason I'm say it,
but
the system and if like you know
certain things got too high,
like human waste of human waste cause a
certain amount of disease which it does,
you know things where we fuck things
up cause a certain amount of debt.
It's almost like cancer with
Saks you lost me fellow.
Yeah.
If you have sex then that's the
planet's way of getting back.
Like stop having sex.
Then did you read the fucking Bible
and we're going to make cancer.
So if you stop having never mind,
I don't know about,
oh my God,
I think I kind of like what
if it was connected cancer,
the worst thing in the real connected
with the best thing in the world.
Kind of like the same kind of Carmen.
We'll see what happens when you get high
is that the eye is what I think is that
you have a paragraph in your head.
It's very well thought out,
but all you can piece together like five
words out of that paragraph and your
brain's scrambled and
picks the five best ones.
And the worst is when you're
halfway into the paragraph and go,
what the fuck?
Talking about
it is the worst
that out.
If it was a normal thing,
oh you know how awesome I would look.
And then you would look and we would all
look at the edited all these things and
like our [inaudible] friends,
I give an that.
I'm fucking those best of
the Brian Clips on Youtube.
They made me laugh.
So fucking hard.
Cause there's something I'm very similar
to Brian and a lot of ways is that
we're,
I think we're both very childish.
Both have their child heart.
And so I hear some of these things and
I can tell when he's trying to be funny.
I can tell he's trying to be serious.
I fucking laughed in a
hotel room bed for an hour,
just watching it over and over again.
That's pretty ridiculous.
Which you call out all the best moments,
you know the best.
My favorite one is when he goes,
my dad has magic glasses,
you can one can see up close in one.
And then I'm,
I'm listening and I go,
they're called bifocals ass judgment.
Franklin had their own business.
My Dad only has back in Ohio,
bought one of those things where
it's a belt that goes around really,
really fast and it has like
these metal prongs that,
that I just hover over the belt,
the rubber belts,
so in it collects electricity and then
you put this little dome on it and the
electricity then collects
inside the dome and it gets off.
I think it's 20,000 volts of electricity
it makes or something like that quiz.
And so he's showing this
to me and he's like,
he's like,
he's,
let me see,
this is what he's doing on his free time.
He's like,
look,
here's all these batteries
like lined up and he's wires.
He's like,
I'm trying to have the electricity
conduct and copper wires and,
and he's like explaining like this whole,
and he's like,
if I could figure this out,
we're going to be billionaires.
And I'm like,
what?
And he goes,
watch what happens when I turn
off the light and he puts that,
he takes a metal hammer with our rubber
thing and he just holds it out the
thing.
And the electricity just starts
shooting towards the hammer.
And then in between,
you know,
the Perri pullout nails,
like the Little v thing and just
electricity's going back and forth really,
really fast.
And it's like,
I was like,
Dad,
what the fuck are you need to start
smoking weed because this is really cool.
If you were high just going into this
little fucking thing that he's got to Domo
written.
No,
he just,
he just holds onto the rubber of the,
the,
the hammer to your dad.
Didn't you get your dad?
No,
it was,
we'd pop.
So soda.
Yeah,
he didn't know.
He didn't know dosed him.
Really?
Dude,
I have it on video.
Awesome.
So why did you dose your dad?
Uh,
because I wanted him,
I wanted to see what would happen.
Oh my God,
mother fucker.
You know what happened?
He became very giggly and laughing
and happy and it was really cute.
And I have never told him about it,
but I have it on a video.
And why would you tell him?
You tell him.
Cause I,
cause you know,
it was like,
I don't know.
I didn't because I wanted
it because we were,
he was hanging out at my house.
I in California,
he was in town for work and he was like,
I only got to see him one night.
And he was hanging out with us having us.
He's,
he likes to drink,
he likes to have a couple of drinks,
have a cocktail.
Right,
right.
He was having fun.
And then,
so we were all sitting
around and I think you are,
somebody gave me a bottle,
this huge,
huge champagne bottle.
It looked like a champagne bottle,
but it was a pop soda pop.
And so I poured a glass and
Katie podcast and I was like,
Dad,
do you want some of this?
And like I said,
it kind of like,
I don't know if he knows what this is,
but he's like,
sure,
I'll have some of that.
And I'm like,
okay.
And then I just gave it to him.
And,
and,
uh,
it started off with,
you know,
my dad was just,
talking like he usually does,
you know,
about how to,
break perpetual motion or
whatever he always talks about.
And then,
uh,
then he just became
giggly and happy and he,
it was just like shitty
grin the whole time.
It's so great.
Wouldn't you tell him about this?
I don't know.
I guess it is like a big yeah,
but it seems like he enjoyed it.
Yeah.
And I think it seems like,
yeah,
but he,
he was a real job.
He would've got drug tested.
I would've,
he would've got fired from his job.
He gets drug test.
I swear.
I've never smoked pot in my life.
Well,
according to your hair follicles,
three weeks ago,
you were higher than front.
It was a long time ago.
I could never do it.
My Dad,
my dad would fucking,
oh wow.
I just don't know why you
wouldn't just tell them.
I know I will.
One day
lead becomes legal in Ohio.
I will tell,
I can't imagine my life like
five years I've told me so crazy,
dude.
Just tell them
or better yet guys and were listening
and you know Brian [inaudible] I'll do
that.
Let me tell him.
Let me tell him so I could videotape it.
What the Fuck did you dad do to when you
were young that you want to torture him
like this?
He made me look at the his inventions
and machines you've dealt with hours and
hours on end.
I just sat there and watched.
That's what we did.
Wires like there's,
there's a picture of me like
on a old school computer on,
have you ever seen me tweeted or whatever
and I'm just like playing on this old
like I don't know what it was.
Machine.
And that's pretty much what I did.
Like every night I would go downstairs
and watch my dad tried to invent crazy
shit and fix things.
Like he's one of those guys that you
could give him anything and he would fix
it.
Like anything.
Like you give them a TV,
you give him a fucking car,
he'll take apart the car and
figuring out what's wrong with him.
Rebuild.
Like if that part isn't made anymore,
he would build that part.
And what's crazy sounds
like your dad Mike.
Like my like math better.
Yeah.
To be a fun drug for your dad.
He got Adderall.
Adderall.
Close some shit down.
Right.
Works like I love those lights.
Dude got in the Adderall
and went on a rage.
Who did?
Brian.
What other luck on the
Adderall rates actually have?
My Dad's showing his computer machine.
You could hear how he talks.
It's fucking crazy.
Love to hear.
All right,
let's,
let's listen to my dad talk about it.
This is him going into his workshop
explaining his electricity machine or when
should you be giving this
stuff out on the air?
I mean,
is this like a patent or
anything that your dad
generator now this hammer still shocked.
So I use this one going,
I buy their handle.
Anything sharp like this.
It doesn't spark to it
like a lightning rod,
you know?
Can we turn the light off?
I think it will probably work in the dark.
Okay.
Oh my God.
I was like Mister Science.
Yeah.
You have to get your eyes used to the car.
It was so scary because
you can't see in the video,
but there's like blue
light sparkling in there.
See the glow come over to the hammer.
Yeah.
So I know,
I hear you're an interesting,
but people don't understand
is this is in the dark.
Okay.
He's showing us the skinnies got it
was like one of those Tesla machines.
Is that,
yeah,
that's why it's something like that.
Yeah.
So it's got what he's got.
One is Tesla machines.
He's got,
it's not a big laboratory either.
No,
it's a,
it's a little work space
that he built the other day.
Recently he built the whole thing.
He just like tore down.
I like the side of his house,
like,
like with a sledge hammer and built
this humongous workshop for him.
And the other day he was like,
I'm going to buy new cars.
We buy new cars.
So we extended his garage by two,
two cars.
Personal,
married.
No,
they're divorced.
They,
he's been remarried for like,
I don't know,
1520 years or something like that.
That's a lot like you,
I guess.
Like you're,
you like that you're like
the tip figure shit out.
Yeah.
He pretty much,
if there was computers,
yeah,
when he was my age,
he would be doing the
same thing with computers.
Would you like your,
your creativity with computers and that,
you know,
just your,
you're from hundred percent.
Really?
Wow.
That's,
that's amazing,
isn't it?
How that can be translated.
You ever met like the children of
singers who can just naturally sing?
Oh yeah.
Fuck yeah.
My kids are naturally,
like I genuinely say my
kids are naturally funny.
Really?
Oh,
100%.
Like my kids are like,
they make other people laugh.
Like,
uh,
like how old are your kids?
Five and seven.
And they're fucking funny.
I don't know,
think it's from being around you been
around a comic or do you think it's
genetic?
I think two things.
I think one is being around me and I'm
co I'm constantly lighthearted and I will
always fucking,
my goal for everything is
laughter about everything.
And then I think also that I have a group
of friends that run through my house
and my kids had been around and
they try to make them laugh.
And I think that that takes up to the,
you know,
it's like,
look,
if you're sitting in the Baptist church
and nothing has happened to people at
all,
but if you're sitting in a Baptist church,
you're trying to make
the baptist preacher lap,
it's pretty easy laugh.
You don't really eat,
oh,
isn't that right?
Good job like it.
But it's not like a cultivated
like sense of humor.
But when you got Thompson gorilla sitting
on the couch and he's drinking beers
and my kids are trying to make them laugh,
they come up with some
funny fucking my daughter.
Yeah.
I,
this is going to sound like a lie because
I'm just telling you this yesterday.
This is maybe the hardest
I've ever laughed at.
My youngest daughter,
my wife was trying to brag on the fact
that her and my youngest daughter who
were having problems
with developmental leave,
she's not retarded.
But that sounds horrible to fuck.
I shouldn't be talking because she's not,
she's not.
She just an emotionally,
she's a a very wild kid.
She's a spirited child.
Okay.
So my wife's trying to
brag on her to a stranger.
I swear to God right now.
Okay,
well life goes island.
I had been playing cooties and I say,
this lady,
Kathy's is sitting right there.
Really?
She goes,
yeah,
and I love,
what do we say when we,
when we lose a turn on Cody's and
Eila without missing a beat goes,
fuck your mother.
And I fucking fell apart
laughing at my wife goes,
no,
no.
And I'm laughing so hard.
I,
let's go.
Fuck your mother.
Your mother and I think goes,
no.
He said,
my mom,
my wife's going,
no.
We say,
Gosh darn it got started.
Dagnabit Lincoln,
I legos and then I'll adjust then
because she knows she's got a laugh.
She fucking,
everything's fucked.
Your mother that day,
it was five years old.
Fuck your mother.
Fuck.
I swear to you on both
of my children's life,
that is exactly what
happened in Leham was like,
I don't know where she heard that.
I was like,
if someone said,
that's fine,
isn't it?
That's the big concern amongst people
that are raising children is your kids
learning how to swear and swearing and
that being a sign of bad parenting.
Oh,
I'm a horrible parent.
That's foolish.
It's so foolish.
The idea that you're going to exclude
certain words and that somehow or another,
this excluding of certain words is
going to make people behave differently.
Is it really are going to
be comments is what it is.
You can't change things by removing Fox
and you know like if a little kid say
fuck,
it's funny what it was it,
it's really bad.
It's bad.
If you over fuck,
you know,
if you're talking to him guys like this
fucking guy with his fucking thing till
the fucking,
after awhile you're like,
dude,
you're killing my head.
Like the way you're
communicating is bizarre.
It's not,
it's not comfortable.
I'm not receiving your
information very comfortably but,
but just the occasional use of the word
that you want to use in the right place.
I mean there's a reason
why those words exist.
Just because some folks aren't that good
at using all the colors to paint with.
It doesn't mean that those
boards should be excluded.
So I always get offended when people
say that their kids shouldn't swear.
I'm like,
really?
You know what?
When is this going to stop?
What is this nonsense of
bad words going to stop?
Well,
if he started off young then that
it would never be a big deal.
You know?
Exactly.
Like if there's a reason
why in European countries,
a lot of kids get to
drink and smoke house.
I was just in Italy and they
were talking about this.
All the kids,
all of them were like,
well,
it's not a big deal in our house.
I got up wine if I want,
so why would I care
about getting fucked up?
They don't have as many issues.
I think a lot of our issues with
things that people have like as far as
obsessive compulsive issues or,
or a addictive issues,
I think it's just a little game that
your brain plays when you can't get
something.
Then he'd get it and he shouldn't
have it and then you want it.
I think it's just this weird seesaw thing
that your brain can play and that and
part that one of the triggers
of that is suppressing people.
So look,
when we all know this,
we all knew this growing up.
Who were the sluttiest girls?
Catholic school girl.
I say black.
When I was growing up
that actually had to go
to the Catholic school.
They had to go to like all girls schools
be academy was where our roles when
they suppressed the
shit out of these girls,
man,
they made them wear these little dresses
and they told him to stay away from
boys.
And I remember I dated two different girls
that went to Catholic school and they
were both fucking free like,
and when you're that age,
when you get introduced to a freak,
that way it blows your fucking mind.
They just couldn't wait to get ahold of
some Dick because they were just told to
stay away,
stay away.
I didn't realize what they're
creating and those women.
And plus it's like those,
it's still the savage blood lines.
It's all Irish and Italian
and all these people in the,
in the Catholic school that's,
those are savage bloodlines,
man.
Those are blood lines of,
you know,
people that have been cutting people
with swords for thousands of years.
You know,
it's,
it's an old European Cuban
that was all Catholic.
Girls' schools were Cuban.
Can I keep them away from Dick too?
I remember this chick,
this chick Shannon,
ninth grade start dating her.
I go to her house,
Catholic from academy and we'd go to,
I go to her house for a date,
like to hang out in her dad
won't let her fucking leave.
So she goes,
well,
we were just sitting here down
and watch a movie and he goes,
well,
I'll be in the kitchen like a wall away,
right second he gets to there,
she grabs my hand,
starts sucking my fingers and I
came with my peers
because I was fucking
jacking off until then,
I had no concept and I remember I made
the mistake of telling everyone at
school,
I'll never forget.
I showed up and they told ty Rodriguez
and tired and I sat down for lunch and
ties like,
cause who came in as parents.
Oh Man,
you fucking Dick.
And then I think that's where I got my
sense of humor is because I ended up,
you have to defend that in
a weird way too fucking,
you can't be the guy that's a stud.
You the guy that came in
so by that girls suck in your fingers.
She gave you a career in comedy.
Probably is man.
I was,
I was cool up until then,
like I was fucking stud.
Shannon,
what's her fucking last name?
I had to find her on Facebook.
Oh Shit.
There's this guy used to gate
that every time after sex,
like when we're spooning going to bed,
like I always have like one arm
underneath her head and the other arm,
she always wanted me
to put it in her mouth,
like the suck or Oh I found out that
she liked it best after trial and error,
that she always liked it
better when like on the nose.
So I would,
I wish she would suck my
thumb until she fell asleep.
And then like I would have
like grandmother phone,
you know,
where he gets off wrinkly and I'd be like,
I know that it was high.
It was high.
It was like baby while I know you're
fucking finger nails not clean.
Oh,
she made them clean so
that if you look at mine,
if you look at my phone and
it's always the cleanest one.
And then sometimes like we would drink
cranberry vodkas or whatever and like I
would have like a stain thumb and it was
kind of embarrassed because you can't
really wash the stain of the
cranberry off of your thumb.
So he would walk around with a red thumb.
We know.
Um,
do you know,
Whoa,
that Guy Julian Assan from wikileaks,
they got it's in trouble.
And is they do want to export it
to be honest with sexual assault,
the League says by,
no,
the story,
I don't know any of the really crazy
this guy released all these documents,
but what they're getting them on,
what they're,
they're prosecuting them on
is having sex with a girl.
He had sex with a girl with a condom
on and then while they were sleeping
together,
he apparently stuck it in without a condom
and was fucking her without a condom.
And she charged him.
It's like sexual surprise
or a surprise sex.
Like for real,
it's not a real thing.
Yeah.
I'm not,
I'm not even joking.
And this is like literally why they're,
they're making this guy like live in a
house arrest and constantly have to check
in and that,
I mean,
it's the ball busting of him for,
for this one thing is,
is extraordinary.
It's like,
it's really confusing like how
much they're going after this guy.
But it's really not about that.
Of course,
it's about the Wiki leaks.
Wiki leaks is an organization that
they got a bunch of documents from,
uh,
someone who was in the army and a lot of
it was like very controversial and uh,
it just horrible shit.
Like one of them,
they put out a video called collateral
murder and it showed these guys that are,
uh,
you know,
in these helicopters,
he's a fighter,
jets,
whatever the fuck they were shooting from,
I think it was a helicopter.
And um,
they're uh,
they're shooting on civilians
and they're shooting on they,
you know,
they think that these
people have guns and they,
in fact they have cameras and they open
up on these people and they open up and
these people that we're putting kids in
there fucking minivan and when they hear
that they had kids in the car,
they go up.
Shouldn't been bringing
kids with them anyway.
Like that was like their responses.
Like you shouldn't have
been bringing kids.
Like,
it's not that we had to cut them down
with these fucking 50 caliber rounds.
No,
they shouldn't been bringing the kids in.
The first one is,
what are we going to do?
It is what it is.
Shouldn't been bringing kids.
It's like they're the glee in being
able to take these people out,
like video games.
You a soldier guy and then they
put this video out and there was,
you know,
really controversial people
saying it's terrible for morale.
It's this is that it
shouldn't have been released.
And then it turns out that
there's a fuck load of documents,
all kinds of shit that they
didn't want to have release in.
This kid had gotten ahold of this stuff
and pass it off to wikileaks and this
kid is still in solitary confinement.
This kid is not Julian as lunch.
No,
no,
no.
He's a,
I forget his name.
Uh,
he's a,
uh,
Avery.
What is his name?
Let me see.
I'll,
I'll look it up.
Um,
so the,
so then the US government
decided to go after wikileaks.
Exactly.
Then just basically fucking
comb through this dude's life.
Yeah.
Bradley Manning is the guy's name.
He's a,
he's a,
yeah,
he's still in,
I believe he's in solitary confinement.
I think he has great a years five.
They caught him and they just
stuffed them in a cell and that's it.
It's really scary shit.
They wait.
Julian Assange g is
the dude who leaked it.
If it's a website.
[inaudible] is Julian Assange is the guy
who ran wikileaks and he's the guy who
leaked all this information.
What's really crazy is that
after it leaves the information,
then the sex charge comes up and they
want to export them out of the country.
I think the Norway where they have
these crazy sex laws like they have
different,
you know,
people have weird laws on rape know this
is where there's some feminists that
believe,
and I've,
I've actually written it,
I've read this and had to go back and
read it several times just to really wrap
my head around whether or not I,
I,
I heard them right then the statement
was that they believe that if a woman has
been tricked by a man and deceived by a
man and to having and talked into having
sex,
then that's rape
and that's every girl
I've ever had sex with
every girl.
I mean,
isn't that amazing that you could,
you should have the right,
if you feel deceived after the act,
after the voluntary act of intercourse.
And she thought
like if the,
if she tells you,
if she just thought you were a good guy,
I mean,
but to call that rape is crazy.
That's,
that is deception.
But the sex was voluntary
so it cannot be raped.
And just because you feel bad about
something that you were coerced into doing
that wasn't illegal.
Yeah.
What if you come really fast?
I'd be good at it and I've
never been good at it,
but it's not illegal.
It's sex.
Rape is illegal.
So you can't make sex rape.
You're turning it into rape.
It wasn't rape.
You were tricked.
Yes,
but it was sex.
You had voluntary sex,
like to call that rape.
That is anybody that would even think
that that would be an acceptable idea is
an anti human that's,
that's anti human.
I will go for,
I'll go as far to say that I believe.
I mean,
if you have me to put it down,
I believe that rape is when a man,
uh,
assaults a woman,
assaults a woman and
makes her do something.
She makes her have sex
when she does not want to.
And I do believe there is a gray
line that we're date rape does,
is involved.
I do believe there are guys that,
that force it.
And the woman's saying no,
but they do it.
Yes.
And I believe there's also a
great line where women are drunk,
too drunk.
And guys take advantage of,
I'm a dude,
I've been around dudes my whole
life and I know that's happened.
I'm at present,
have done that.
And the,
and they as they walk
you through the night,
you're like,
sounds a little rapey to me.
But,
but,
but the,
I mean,
as they walk you through the night,
yeah.
You're like,
Ooh,
you didn't watch.
And you're like,
Huh,
maybe I should report you.
So,
um,
but I do believe that because this is not
the subject I everyone's talking about
because it's a,
like I went to college
when the word rape became,
um,
flip floppy and like chicks were saying
they got raped when they genuinely
didn't,
do you know what I mean?
Like the word rape was a buzzword and
so women were using the word rape,
like throwing it out there.
And then I think,
right,
like right after that is when
comics got ahold of the word rape,
like Sarah Silverman and
made it a joke and took it.
That's why I love Sarah,
man.
I'll fucking always love
that chick because she took
things that I think I would
joke about with my friends and as a woman
said them on stage and I thought I was
like,
fucking gangster dude.
Fucking roles.
Definitely gangster.
She's funny,
man.
She should be a supreme court judge.
Whatever she says is right.
That should be it.
Like there are women,
I mean,
well,
I dunno,
I'm fucking,
what am I talking about?
Well,
it's human beings have to have their shit
together in order to be able to judge
people.
And it's been pretty obvious that the
system that they're judging people under
right now is just so flawed
and fucked up and no,
no,
no one's saying that it should all be
dismantled and that that's what's going to
have to happen.
We're going to have to do,
it would have to dismantle the
whole system to make anything fair.
You know,
Preme Court justice to
Supreme Court period.
All your crazy fucking laws.
Jesus man,
I heard a honeycomb,
a bullshit.
I heard Chris rock say something
one time that kind of fucking,
that redefined everything.
Men I've had like things redefined
for me within the last few months.
So big man,
like so big.
We were talking about ego.
I fucking,
my ego is,
is uh,
that concept of ego.
I've never understood.
I fucking now understand,
but Chris Rock said something about
was Saturday night live racist.
I don't know where I heard it on.
And he was saying,
no,
it's not racist,
but there is a shorthand would that two
white guys have that a black and white
guy don't have like two white guys
like and Michael and say Chris Farley,
there's a shorthand that they have
that a black kid is not born with.
And when I heard that I went,
what do you mean by shorthand?
Okay.
Like,
um,
like,
uh,
like going into a meeting with a bunch
of white dudes and you just kind of,
you understand them and like,
or like when a guy goes,
man,
how about that fucking Diaz fight?
And then all of a sudden you and him
have a shorthand and you go to a meeting,
you're like,
oh,
we have something in common.
We can talk without,
we know each other without having to
dudes love doing shit like that.
And it's why I didn't play
golf together and stuff.
Right,
exactly.
It's in white guys love it more than any,
I mean,
black guys love it too,
but what happens is your shorthand
comes from the people you grew up with.
Like I know white dudes
who are in fraternities.
Like,
I don't even need to
fucking say a word to them.
I can tell you what they do.
I can tell you how to act
when the cameras aren't on.
I can tell you how I can tell
you everything about them.
Right.
But black dudes,
my shorthand is based on like pretty
much like the dude's I'd partied with in
New York.
Like,
cause I don't,
I just don't know brothers.
And like,
I know like Godfrey Rd,
Tony Woods that night when Tracy Morgan,
like those are my,
that's my shorthand.
So I see what you're saying.
So you're saying that there's,
that white guys on Saturday night
live have more connectedness.
They all went to Harvard.
They all went to college.
They're all into comedy.
They all had the same comedy upbringing.
Like they all had parents
that's probably either divorced,
like they're part of the system,
right?
Lauren Michaels,
Michaels being the head.
But she,
Chris Rock was saying
as a kid from Brooklyn,
his shorthand wasn't there.
So when he met Lauren Michaels,
he didn't,
he didn't know the like,
I mean,
ultimately,
you know,
it's like when you meet
a network executive,
I kind of know what to
say and what not to say.
And I know how to act.
I know to wear a collared shirt if it's
right and I know not to because I'm
white.
I'm done.
I've had to deal with white
men my whole fucking life.
Like Chris Rock.
Never if he dealt with a white man.
Um,
I'm guessing this is speculation
based on an interview,
but it was like a,
it was a cop or a Joe going
to say he never got arrested.
But you know what I mean?
Like when he saw white men,
who was it from a different place,
his average black man was
like a dad or a friend's dad.
Those guys aren't running Saturday
night live or running heads of business.
That blew me away.
That concept of,
of,
of racism not being how people act,
but just being like as
common as a shorthand.
Like,
you know,
like that's very astute of him to point
it out to all it's fucking genius,
man.
That guy blows me away consistently
because the way he sees life,
like I was just hearing,
I was talking to one of his
contractors and he was like,
this contractor was like
putting a window in his house.
Now this is the difference
between Chris Rock,
the Rock,
the window was $20,000 and
he's putting his house.
I'm sure I'm not supposed
to be talking about this.
Why are you doing?
Why are you doing it?
I'm telling you,
you guys had to control my ego.
He said,
no.
Anyway,
the window,
um,
it's an interesting story.
So we put some window and it's $20,000.
The guy goes,
hey look,
I'll copy the one.
I'll give you the window if you let
me fucking put your mind TV show or
whatever,
and like show that I'm
doing Chris Rock's house.
Chris Rock's like,
man,
if I show my family,
I'm putting in a $20,000
a window into a house,
they're going to want
to stay in that house.
Like,
I can't just fucking put
that on TV and I was like,
oh,
I fucking put that shit on TV because
my ego would come in and be like,
fucking Bam.
Let's show everyone.
I mean,
why were you saying before that you
were having a problem with your ego?
I just damn man,
it's genuine.
You're,
you're not,
you're,
I,
I'm going to ask you to go back probably
15 years and try to connect to yourself
then.
Okay.
You've done a lot of work
I think on yourself that a
lot of people haven't done.
So you know when people just go,
when people just say like that you show
up to a bunch of comics and they're
like,
everyone's like,
yeah,
we won't shut up too.
And he's like,
ah,
I got to sit calm on this.
I got sick,
I'm on Mat.
And then you just,
you,
I was talking to Brian,
you just casually try to slide
in what you're doing casually.
Like oh that's so cool.
I know Brian.
Yeah,
I'm doing a thing with them like
and then and that to me is fucking,
it's so unhealthy.
It's the next self bragging self Bragg
and like it's so unhealthy and it's so
disconnects your heart.
This is what I've been thinking
disconnects your heart from humanity,
right?
It,
it,
what it does is it puts your brain in it
cause your brain starts talking to your
heart going,
hey man,
we're hurting in your
brain and your hearts.
Like why?
He's like,
because you read what he's doing,
he's doing a bunch of shit.
You're not doing shit.
And he's like,
well then fuck you start to so,
so you,
you hear other people talk about the
stuff that they're doing and you want to
pump yourself up.
Is that what you're saying?
You almost have to do
a better hand at cards.
Like I like try to one,
I'm trying to,
one up,
I had a conversation when we say,
let me the friend and he's a nice guy,
he's a comic.
And uh,
I ran into him and I said,
hey,
what's up man?
And he just went on this embarrassing
run about some development deal and this
and if it doesn't go out,
I have a buyout and Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
And they've said that
this is their number.
And I'm like,
Whoa,
really?
You know?
And then if that doesn't work,
I've got to develop
and it just went on and I'm like,
I meant hi.
I'm like,
he does good to see you.
You cannot be,
yes,
your heart's connected to him.
This is going to sound good.
Can I get some Celine
Dion music in the back of
your heart's connected
with him when you said,
how are you doing?
You are genuinely asking,
see his head was connected to you.
What does his Joe Rogan,
he's got this going on.
I need to prove to him that it seems
like he probably left that conversation
going.
That went perfect.
I think one of the nicest things,
hey,
do not put Celine Dion.
We'll start fucking dick under the table.
I,
I'd like doing a lot of different things.
I don't want to have my whole entire
identity to connect it to one thing,
you know?
And whether it's one thing in,
in my life,
whether it's one thing and what,
what my occupation is,
I just think there's a,
this,
there's a lot to be gained
in flexibility and you know,
in,
in being able to do a bunch of different
things and not having to rely on one,
I've been able to like
not have to define myself,
you know,
I'll do whatever the fuck I do.
I do what I do.
You know,
like to worry about the world of
comedy or worry about the world of MMA.
A worry of I just do my shit
we have now.
That's you and that you are
not the average of people.
Yeah,
but I think everybody can do it.
I think everyone can do it.
When I heard you talking,
I was in Europe and I,
you know,
I fall asleep,
I listened to show when I sleep I put a
play it all night long and I just have
it on repeat so I hear it all night long.
It's one of the greatest things
if you don't already do that,
that I'm telling you when I say that's
the greatest way to fucking listen to
podcasts because you feel like you're
hanging out with friends and they're in
the other room and you're safe.
And I get lonely on the road.
It's even better when it's you
on the podcast and you hear,
I heard me talking to you
and I was fucking right.
I was like,
Oh,
and I'm in my own dream
with you and I'm like,
bug and this is awesome.
So,
but,
um,
there's no like,
uh,
like I was listening to you talking
about ego destroying ego with drugs,
with,
with um,
getting into the tank and
getting rid of your ego.
And I was like,
man,
my,
and I started thinking
about ego and I was like,
where's my ego?
Oh No,
I just saw myself
fucking arguing with people.
Like,
not arguing,
but being argumentative,
being difficult just about ego based Shit.
Like someone would say,
this guy was a great host on this show,
my crew,
and I'd be like,
in my head,
my head is going to fuck their gallery.
You're better than him.
But I have not even.
Yeah.
And so I've been doing a lot of
work on my ego and trying to,
like I did in front of Ari last night,
but I'll fucking own this shit.
I saw Ari lessons.
When you say you're
doing work on your ego,
what do you mean?
Like when you don't,
I'm biting my tongue and I'm letting
myself feel the fucking disgusting
feelings.
When you,
you get a t,
when you feel like,
when you feel like [inaudible] statement
is directed at you like last night
some,
this is the bad eggs.
I don't even want to
fucking use that example.
Nevermind.
I'm not going to use that example because
ends up fucking really bad example.
But Ari was,
Ari saw me fucking bike.
I started saying,
I started to Brag,
I started to say something
to brag and then I went,
I stopped myself out loud.
And when I'm not doing that and he goes,
what?
And I go,
I'm not saying what I'm about to
say cause it's a fucking stupid.
This is stupid.
So that's what I'm trying to do.
I'm trying to be more connected
to people by my heart and,
and hear what they're saying as a human.
Just like when someone goes,
hey man,
how,
what are you up to you as a comic?
You hear that and you're like,
what do I have to,
I have a,
I have this going on.
Not like,
oh my grades are good.
They have a violin recital tomorrow.
Like not like real shit,
you know?
Well,
you know,
I think as a human being,
when you,
you have something that's your occupation
or something that you're obsessed
with,
I think,
uh,
there,
you build up a lot of stress when you're
pursuing something and a lot of that
stress can be evacuated physically.
And that's what a lot of
people aren't aware of.
Like I goof around and,
and you know,
and talk to people about,
uh,
you know about yoga and
goof on yoga people.
But Yoga is like a brilliant way of
managing your emotions and your body.
And,
and the idea of the word centered.
I hate the,
I hate,
I hate crystal talk.
You know what I'm saying?
I hate,
you know,
well my yoga going on a retreat,
there's a cleanse that's a
fucking teacher by the way.
I hate crystal.
I crystal talk.
It drives me nuts.
I hate,
I hate it when I know that it's a,
you're just,
you've accepted this,
this new age ideology,
this,
you know,
and,
and there's a lot of yoga talk
that goes along with that.
But Yoga as a practice
is a brilliant practice.
It's fucking hard to do,
man.
There's people that like,
oh you're,
you're working out.
Oh you're doing yoga.
That's not working out the fuck.
It's not man Yoga.
It's hard.
Some of the worst ass kickings I've ever
had of Jujitsu was when I did yoga in
the morning and then do Jujitsu at night.
Yeah.
Cause your beat,
I'm fucking beat.
You know,
I didn't,
I did it like I don't like I can
fucking do yoga in the morning.
I'm not going to be tired for Jujitsu.
Fucking not man.
Some of those poses are really difficult
and they're designed to like rain all
the stress out of your
body and they humble you.
You walk out of there when you,
when you have to go
through physical exertion,
physical
exertion,
like to the point where
your body's failing.
That is very humbling,
you know?
And then when you get a speech at the end,
that's what I love about Yoga is you
get into child's pose where you're just
laying there and they talk to you,
man,
I changed my life.
Yeah,
I was,
uh,
in a relationship I wasn't happy with.
This was probably 10 years ago,
right before nine 11 or right after.
Um,
but is that area,
and I was in a relationship.
I wasn't into,
I did not love her.
I didn't even like her.
And I was drinking a ton and I
was fucking as fat as I am now.
But I mean,
I've gotten back,
but I was as fat as I am now and I,
and one morning I was up and I was just
fucking angry and depressed at like six
in the morning.
My Buddy Corey called me and he was like,
Hey,
do you wanna go to yoga?
And I was like,
Fuck Yoga,
I'm not going to yoga.
He goes,
took good workout man,
you'll enjoy it.
Did Yoga at the end of Yoga.
And I did every pose with integrity.
I like did them,
I was sweating like a bitch laid down in
child's pose and this dude with fucking
sleep and tattoos.
Cool motherfucker like just walks
around in yoga pants and he's like,
what?
And he's talking to cross.
What do you hate in your life today?
What bothers you?
And just because I'm exhausted,
I'm exhausted.
I am tapped out physically.
My brain just went fucking Rachel.
And he goes,
you can change that.
And I was like,
I can't,
it's too hard.
And he goes,
decided to change that today,
decide to make that decision
today and tomorrow will be better.
You do that right now.
And I was like,
I guess I can bring up,
but there are any,
and then I just want to go,
yes you can,
you can do that.
And I was like,
I could fucking break up with
her and like the dumbest thing,
I was like,
I'm gonna fucking break up with her,
fucking bring up this bitch.
Fuck this.
And I called her glass.
I was like,
it's over it.
She was like,
what was like,
we should go to dinner,
let's talk click.
But yeah,
it was,
and I fucking did it and went this chick,
I was,
no,
I was dating her and we were like
dated for like a couple of years.
We weren't living with them.
No,
no,
no.
And so I got fucking broke
up with her literally.
And I was like,
the whole thing about
that one class was like,
lose weight,
man.
I can lose weight.
I just know how to lose weight.
You just got to work out like a beast.
Eat healthy.
That's the way to lose weight.
Fuck a book.
So I started losing weight.
I got down to 185 pounds,
dude.
I was a gangster.
Brian,
if you pull up my,
my,
my Facebook page it on my fan Facebook
page at Burke Chrysler where I'm singing
on the Joe,
you'll see this.
I'm Garret.
I'm almost waiting for your reaction
of what you think I look like.
So you got super healthy and
fucking met my wife in a good place.
Fucking fell in love.
Changed my life.
I'm the happiest man in the world.
And you think it's
attributable to that one?
One to fuck last breaking guys speech.
The one dude man,
one day.
Isn't that funny?
Like,
you know,
I hate that expression.
The wings of a butterfly can be the
first steps in and there's a hard cane.
Yeah,
there's many wings.
I mean,
my girlfriend,
my girlfriend in college also fucked
my best friend and gave me the class.
Yeah.
So that what I know.
So that's part of talk to me.
What is this?
She fucked my best when I was in Russia.
She was fucking my best friend.
Oh my God.
Who had the biggest dick in the world?
Like I need to know that.
Wow,
your best friend fucked your girlfriend.
Yeah.
And it happened to me in high school
and then they went to my graduation like
with his family or with her family.
Brian,
go to my pictures.
I know you're all medically handbook.
Yeah,
go to my pictures on my fan page where
I'm singing on top of the Braves.
Oh right.
Yeah,
that's it.
And you'll see no,
no it did that page.
And then just scroll through and
you'll see one of me shirtless.
You'll go,
are you fucking kidding me?
So,
um,
so this was the wings of the butterfly.
This turned you into one of the
many wings of the butterfly.
You know,
you have a few uncomfortably dumb,
but this was a big one.
I don't know.
Brian,
what were your wings?
My wings.
What does my wins?
I'm like,
give me some moments where you went,
well,
this is what I do for now on.
I'm a,
I'm real good at
commanding to shit.
Like if I like to do something,
I'm real good at like throwing my entire
brain at it and becoming obsessed with
it.
It's probably not healthy.
It's probably like a
lot of success I think.
And this is my belief about like,
uh,
athletics that a lot of
success in athletics,
it comes down to almost like a psychosis.
You know,
like there's did like a and a
real high level of anything.
There's a certain amount of,
uh,
almost crazy behavior to get to this
incredible position like a Michael Jordan
or,
uh,
you know,
or uh,
or Muhammad Ali or you know,
any,
any like elite highly
Mike Tyson in his prime.
And this,
there's a madness,
you know,
and I,
from the time that I was a kid,
I was involved in martial arts,
so it wasn't like,
it was like a choice that I
made when I was like 14 or 15.
And that was a choice that I was on it.
So I was like 21 I know.
But when I realized that I had to stop
fighting and stop teaching and just do
comedy was I was talking to a kid,
his name is Jonathan.
I wish I remembered his last name,
but we were open.
Miker is together about
six months in a comedy.
I was still dabbling in it and I still
had my feet in all my other worlds trying
to find my place.
And this dude who I'd done open
mikes with for like six months goes,
you were really funny in the beginning.
But man,
he just kind of petered out after a while
really.
And I was like,
wow.
And I couldn't even say anything
because I knew he was right.
Oh it was.
Yeah.
I couldn't say anything.
I couldn't say anything cause in my head,
you know,
like if someone says you
don't work hard enough,
my,
my instinct is always to go fuck you.
But I know as a person who's,
you know,
benefited greatly from very
uncomfortable criticisms before,
like some of the biggest growth moments
you can have was where someone just
knocked your dick into the dirt and
like she know what the fuck is a great
statement and then you step back.
And so I recognized early on to,
you know,
to be able to step back and objective
Lee obsessed when challenged like that.
So it was when that guy said that I,
I wanted to go,
that's a dickhead thing to say
cause you know he was my friend,
but I was,
he's right.
Oh,
I couldn't say anything.
So I said,
this is it.
Fuck this.
I'm,
I'm a fucking professional comedian.
I'm not.
I'm not having one foot in the door.
I closed down my school.
I quit my job.
Yeah.
I was teaching taekwondo
at Boston University and I
had a a school in revere at
Nautilus plus.
That's per Chrysler scan.
Bert Kreischer.
Dude,
you're a fucking animal
Jujitsu studio.
That's when I met my wife.
That's incredible bro.
I can't Bro.
He was like a stud.
You Go,
you could choke somebody.
I was a fucking monster nail.
You get double under hooks on May.
Look at you.
Look at that.
I was fucking gangster.
If you want to see it.
It's on my Facebook,
my Facebook page.
Brian,
I don't know what the name,
is it bird type his name.
Just go to my Facebook page.
Hey,
like me.
Why there?
Why don't you just put that picture up
on your mirror and fucking get up to it
hard.
I'm really trying hard.
You can do that.
I'm trying hard man.
Joe,
I'm not even fucking around.
I have my fitbit.
I try to stay around 20,000 steps a day.
I followed.
That's right.
You have the crazy thing
in carrier fitbit scale.
Have you got Brian explained to people
if they don't know what the fitbit is
fucking money.
Fitbit.
You hear me?
I talk about this thing
all the fucking time.
I don't think they have any money,
dude.
Oh,
are you using it?
And Tom Sara Bet did not updating it
so I get,
I got the fitbit.
This fitbit is fucking,
it counts your steps,
your calories,
your,
your flights of stairs you walk.
It's,
it's the best thing
you put in your pocket.
You just walk around with it.
It just keeps you active.
It counts.
You're coaching the other day.
So do you have a butterfly moment to
cost you to get a flip it a fitbit?
You know what it was going to be dead
honest with you is I bought it and I was
kind of like,
I was like,
oh this is Kinda neat.
And then I brought it here,
I guess I brought here or
to the other studios and um,
I had it and Brian was like,
oh I'm gonna get one.
And then Brian got one and he emailed
me and he was like hip following you on
fitbit that moment I was like,
fuck,
I can't let pride and I swear to you,
I started like,
and then and then all this,
there was a desk squad page I guess and
they were all like fucking and I was
like,
I can't get going.
Don't you guys do this?
Would you both be interested
in getting in shape now
let me tell you something.
Let me,
I'm going to be really honest.
If you don't get your life in order now,
you're going to fucking
pay for it when you're 39.
Yeah,
that's only a year away.
I know that's not sort of
talking about start it today.
Like I've,
I'm trying to fix my life health wise now.
Well that's certainly good
because you know it's going to end
the last years,
you know,
depending on how much
you're poisoning it now,
depends on how well it's going to work
and allows you to feel so fucking good.
What's poison feels good for you?
All of them.
Plus alcohol.
What I'm trying to cut,
I'm cutting.
My drink has been cut back a lot.
You know what else is it?
Yup.
People listen to this Joe.
Oh,
that's right.
You're not a fucking real podcast.
You're fucking this podcast.
Yeah.
Those other podcasts are pussies.
I can fucking talk.
I can say I go do some
podcasts and I'll look for it.
I'll tell you anything you want.
No one's here this.
I was like,
that's fucking bad.
Well,
I don't think that,
I think any podcasts he gets
on the Internet it's going to,
but you know,
in this podcast you man,
you can't not pay up
moments on this podcast.
I talked about shit and I'm like,
and then you lay in bed.
You're like,
it's not like this is Joe and
his friends listening to it.
This is Joe and fucking a lot.
Okay,
let's do this.
Okay.
And he just let it swing.
Let's do this.
Let's celebrate bottle
on a diet or something.
I'm on a diet.
Chevon doesn't count d I'm hiding
behind the campaigns like party stuff.
Um,
so,
and the reason hardy stuff,
yeah,
it's fine.
Grocery get on Sundays.
Oh,
come on.
They do.
They have mimosas.
Yeah.
So this is what,
uh,
this is what we're celebrating.
Okay.
And I say this and I say
this in connection with what
I was just saying and I've
said this to a number of times.
I've said this to so many times that I
have stopped saying it and I've thought a
lot.
And it's the reason I don't call
sometimes when I want to thank you.
But,
uh,
this podcast has been life
changing for a bunch of us.
I think a lot of us that have
done this had been fantastic.
This has been one of the
greatest experiences of our
lives or our professional
careers.
And because of this podcast,
your boy
wrote a book.
You wrote a book.
I've got a book deal son.
Wow.
Book deals coming out in the year and
then just because of this podcast.
Wow.
And it is like one of my coolest life
achievements ever and it's something I'm
so proud of.
It is.
It is something I will dedicate this
next year to it more than anything I'm
working on.
That's,
you know,
obviously not like,
oh is that my book editor?
We're going don't talk about it yet.
So,
uh,
but,
but I I got to thank you man because I,
I got the book deal and that the only
reason I ever been interested in doing a
book cause cause this podcast,
you've got a book deal cause
are an interesting dude,
but there's a lot of the meetings,
you know this better than any man,
you know,
look the meeting showed up
because people heard this podcast.
I appreciate that.
And it's beautiful.
It's awesome to hear word but it
wouldn't have mean meant anything if you
weren't talented.
I do see that.
I appreciate that because I've
said this to a number of times,
but man distinctly this,
uh,
I mean the whole reason the whole
thing came up is this fucking podcast.
Like I went to New York and people had
heard this podcast and they were like,
hey man,
I heard that machine
story on Joe's podcast.
Can you do a book?
And this is the,
that from your podcasts that tape
got passed to all look at it.
Another way of looking at it is how
lucky am I that I get to be on a podcast
with guys?
Like you have such great stories that
make people on tune in and listen again
cause your egos in check.
That's fucking really
sweet of you to say Joe.
But I will genuinely,
it's not that I me to say that
it's 100% how I feel.
I think we're,
we're all real lucky.
You know,
this podcast has been a lot of fun.
It's,
it's,
we got a connection with people that
we never thought would take place,
you know,
and I respect it and I
know Brian respects it and,
and I,
and I know the people that go on the show,
they,
that we,
we're all aware that this is,
this is really cool.
We're all railed aware
that we have like cool,
we have like a,
it's like the impact of like a regular
show and yet you could just film it out
of my fucked up office,
you know?
To me
it's a bizarre,
it's like,
it's like showing up to San
Francisco when the first dude's like,
hey man,
can you guys keep a secret?
It's fun,
you know,
and the connection with people,
like we did a show last night at the
ice house and it was fucking amazing.
It's incredible.
The place is packed.
We,
we,
we sold it out on like one day's notice.
You know,
we just said we're going
to do a show there.
And it was mobbed with the
coolest fucking people.
How bad ass was that chair last night,
Brian?
It's fucking awesome.
Amazing.
That's audiences every Wednesday night.
A late night show too.
We did a 10:00 PM show,
didn't,
you know,
didn't even get started to like 10 30 it.
We're totally changing that
whole entire ice house.
We're,
we're bringing that fucking club back
because I mean a lot of the comics last
night said I used like Doug Benson,
I used to love coming to the ice house,
but then something weird happened and
it just like that and I get started
getting kind of different and it
wasn't that fun to go to anymore.
It's like,
but like tonight he's like,
that was one of the funniest times ever.
The best crowds we've ever had ever.
And it's,
it's almost like hard to believe.
You would assume that you know,
you don't think that people have
really have different crowds.
You don't think that people like bring,
you know what I mean?
You feel like,
well Chicago is different than New
York in New York is different than San
Francisco.
But what's been,
what's changed recently for
us is that everywhere we go,
the crowds have been amazing.
Like really nice people like really
enthusiastic and you got to go,
how the fuck does that happen?
Like how can you pull that off?
Like what is no one ever thought that
there was a formula for doing that.
No one ever thought that there was a
formula where you could go and ensure that
you would have a huge percentage of the
population that kind of thinks along the
same way that you think
would be nice to people.
Be Generous,
but you're making me over.
Think about the way you think though.
Can you imagine it?
You've found those
people like when you go,
hey,
the the blue collar comedy tour,
they found each other.
We'll know shit.
Like,
can you imagine that?
A bunch of people that are into Dmt,
mushrooms and I'm a fucking spiritual,
like vitamins being healthy,
like all those people just showed
up at once and you're like,
shut the fuck up.
Love comedy.
Love good fucking friends,
good stories.
Enjoying each other.
Like there's a comradery that is this,
this network.
Everybody likes good comedy,
Matt.
I think unless you're a con too.
Yeah,
you liked good comedy.
Unless you like,
can I just don't funny unless
you're one of those asshole.
Some people enjoy bad guy,
some people enjoy counted.
It's not good.
Like everyone that I've
heard on your podcast,
I don't think I will.
I don't think there's one exception is
a comic that I would fucking pay to see.
Genuinely.
That's a large statement.
And when you had dom Arrera yeah,
that's like a,
and he's,
so,
he's not a Olympus,
but he's like one of the gods that
deals with like traffic or whatever.
Like he's uh,
one of the fucking 12 gods
and it's a great comment.
His podcast I listen to on repeat when
I was in Boston because I was in Boston
and I was like,
oh,
I'm going to bed.
I'll listen to Dom's over and over.
God,
man,
he was on Tuesday too.
He did Tuesday to monster man.
Like everyone,
I couldn't,
you couldn't name one comic there.
I will say I will,
I will go this far is that
I've become friends with,
uh,
the majority of people that have done
that are regulars on this podcast through
this podcast.
Like Joey Diaz,
Dunkin,
Brian,
Ari,
like those are my,
not my,
not my friends.
And my life has expanded exponentially.
Friend was like that just to
have those guys in my life,
you know,
tap Dunkin at my house the
other day and the man cave,
we're talking about fucking Dunkin Shit.
You know how Dunkin's brainworks and
you'd tell him something and he goes,
oh,
well you're thinking,
it's not that.
It's this call young book.
Like there's that.
And then you're like,
oh,
you want us to go?
And he's like,
fuck you.
We get some cigars in here.
You know,
like,
I hear his voice in my head sometimes,
and to have Ari and like to have
all these people in your life,
come on.
We're very fortunate,
man.
We're all very fortunate.
You know,
it's,
uh,
it's been really interesting.
It's like,
I always,
you know,
we tried to do some stuff before we
did like these little things called Joe
shows when we did,
uh,
videos of everywhere,
we would go,
going,
go call out Jenna Jamison
via Paul being a whore.
No,
I did not.
Oh No,
I was in Nigeria.
Jenna Jamison is nice.
I've never called her
out for being a whore.
How dare you?
She's a nice lady.
Okay.
What'd you get this from?
Oh my God.
Remember that you're confusing me.
I swear to God.
Joe Show you ran into gym,
gender terms on the Joe Show,
right?
No,
no,
no.
Wait,
it was Jenna Jamison explaining to me.
Oh,
to eat pussy.
She's teaching.
Don't calling around to Jameson's.
Cool.
We liked Genentech.
Yeah,
she's very cool.
She's a very nice lady.
You know,
she was not her,
but,
um,
Ginger Lynn was on,
uh,
David tells show last night I did
David tell show Dave's old porn.
That's a fucking fun child,
man.
Really?
If you ever done it?
No.
Why do you laugh?
You could do it.
I can definitely do it.
But you know,
it's like Dave David Tell,
you know,
it's not like he's,
he's calling his buddies
Scott and you stand up.
He's called his friends
is not going to call.
He's like into a casting call for it,
but I think he would love to
deal with any kind of comics.
I'd love to do with Dave and I.
That would be,
that's my feelings when
you go down to yourself,
you sweetie,
cue the music.
But anyway,
yeah.
You know,
just to be sitting there with
Dave Rifkin on guys getting coke.
It was really fun.
And then um,
Ginger Lynn came on,
she watched,
watched their videos.
Old School.
Yeah.
She's one of the,
the the originators and
the Mount Rushmore porn.
She's right up.
So if you could do,
if you could do a tour,
right?
Dream Tour.
No money has no money is
involved you and three comics.
Three you're equals not
like you can't bring Joey.
I'm not,
not to judge that you're equal,
but I'm talking like three
fucking big name draws.
Who would it be?
I wouldn't do that.
You have to.
You have a gun pointed at your bowl.
It's like guys that I
would want to work with.
I would love to do a tour.
Okay.
I would love to do Stan hope.
Norton me and who else want cheese?
I is one of the amazing
monster show that would,
yeah.
Tell him I have talked about
doing some stuff together.
We should totally do that.
Me a towel and stand up would be a
lot of fun on the road to Oh God.
Yeah.
Well,
Luis,
way busy,
man.
He's,
he's so super successful right now.
He's so busy with his own stuff.
I don't think he has time to do anything.
He'd redesigning the
entertainment business.
Yeah,
man.
I mean the fucking guy
produces his own comedy.
Special changes the whole game.
Everybody including me following suit now
produces his own fucking show and it's
on a laptop direct sir.
Rights at all.
I mean,
I'm not asking that.
Got To do shit.
I sent him an email asking
them to do the podcast.
He said he would someday
when he gets time,
but I,
you know,
I'm not pushing it.
He's,
that guy's busy as fuck.
I love having a guy like that out there.
I think it's very inspirational,
Huh?
Yeah.
He inspires me the most of them and
any comedian and not even like material
wise.
If I had to choose between a guy
that makes me the laugh the hardest,
it's Stanhope.
Stan hopes new fucking CD before
he turns the gun on himself.
Yeah,
it's great.
Maybe my maybe like,
oh and I'll put this up there.
Uh,
Patrice is,
last city was great,
but Patrice is our special
elephant in the room.
Oh,
it's fucking awesome.
Yeah,
that was really good.
And Stan hope CD.
I bought it myself.
I purchased it as a consumer and I fucking
listen to it and I was laughing out
loud.
Loudness,
not what my wife likes,
but I had to,
I was like,
I got a tester.
I got to bring her in the room and let
her hear this track cause it's that
fucking funny.
And he's a monster.
He's in town right now or as,
or it was yesterday or the day.
Yeah.
Oh that's right.
Did Dave show?
Yeah,
I got it.
I got to call him up.
Who wants to fucking get behind Gary,
whatever the fuck his name is,
the guy from New Mexico,
former governor of New Mexico.
Then there were some
standout stories that I tell.
He was really crazy.
Oh.
Sitting with a group of um,
shit,
this would be so,
oh,
stupid was sitting with a group of chefs,
Gary Johnson,
sorry.
That's who Stan hope wants to get
behind or similar group of chefs at a,
at a restaurant called camp and Nelly
on Labrea and they were talking about,
they were talking about food.
They're talking about this great
restaurant on Fairfax called animal.
Have you ever been there?
He was just talking about it apparently.
It's like best,
I've never been there.
I'd love to go.
It's amazing.
I they have everything
they have like veal brains.
They have,
it's kind of expensive though,
but I'd heard it's great.
So they're talking about like gossip
about food and what good food places
already eat.
And then I said to them,
I was like,
this is really cool.
It's like being in the green room of
a comedy club and listen to what your
headliners.
Talk about what comic
I should look out for.
And they were like,
well what comics should we look out for?
And I was like,
that's a fucking horrible question.
So I don't even know who are,
who you guys like.
And one of the guys goes,
we love Doug Stanhope.
And I was like,
I didn't see that coming just
because during the corporate world,
you know what I mean?
And I was like,
really?
And they're like,
man,
his last special when we talk,
who likes to be in the corporate world,
how many people are in there
that are enjoying that a lot?
That's just where they're at.
They're stuck,
you know?
That's what a shitty existence.
I would never,
the weirdest thing
about our whole society,
our whole culture is in order for
it to work the way it is right now,
we can go to the store and buy a fucking
soda and getting a car and just turn
the key and drive it.
Someone has to do some shit that they
don't want it everywhere has got to take
it on the Chin every fucking morning.
He got to recognize that unless they can
figure out how to make robots that do
everything.
And then even that,
are you really going to find a guy
that wants to program that robot to do
everything or is it going to be a
job that he has to do and it sucks?
I mean,
there's no way that everybody could
live the life of Bert Kreischer.
It's not possible.
Someone's got to be out there huffing it.
Bert ditches need to be dug,
right?
Yeah.
Some of it,
someone's got to dig a fucking Ninja.
I,
I genuinely look up to those guys
who bill fences sometimes cause I go,
look,
I'm not shitting on my existence at all.
I'm not saying that I have it hard,
but sometimes I do miss
my family and I go,
man,
like I don't have a choice.
I have to go to Scotland for two weeks.
That's great gig to go to Scotland for
two weeks or go to Italy for two weeks,
back to back with three days off.
But it's,
it does suck.
You Miss Your family.
And some days you look at the guy
building the fence and you're like,
Macy's is kids every fucking morning.
And he's like,
and no one gives them notes on his,
his fans like,
hey man,
you gotta like do it
this way a little bit.
Are you getting that from your show?
You get notes and like what to do?
Oh,
of course.
All the time.
I mean,
yeah,
it was an annoying,
uh,
I'm,
you know what I am,
I should,
I should write a book about how to
get through the corporate world of
television.
Like not famous television but making
television and just be cool with it.
Cause I get it,
man.
I totally fucking get it.
I get when they go,
we need more information.
I go,
I,
I'm not the,
despite the fact that we're
not making comedy though,
the grossest things when you're making
comedy and you get the notes like I,
it was way easier for me to,
you know,
to have a bunch of people that have
a bunch of different opinions on how
something should be done on fear factor.
And it would be if they were
trying to deconstruct my stand up.
When you start,
if you've done a comedy central special,
did you have to over
your material with them?
Yeah.
How'd that go and not?
Well,
I had to do it.
I had to do too.
I want the first one I
had to do pat buckles.
I had to go over it with her,
like she read it back to me.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Fucking and I'm about to go onstage and
not one laugh like silence because I'm
not coming out of my shit.
She doesn't understand it.
Of course.
No laugh.
Why would she laugh at you?
Yeah.
Who was a nice person,
but he just was like,
she was like,
card the groove though.
I'll never forget her first thing was,
all right,
so let's do it.
My name is Bert and everything in hot,
sexy name Bert,
Bert,
Bert and I go,
Yep.
He goes,
okay.
Uh,
where all the bitches that
right is that you are.
Here we go.
All right,
we're going to take pitches off.
Can you change that?
Sure.
All right.
Like,
whoa.
Just real like it was well done,
but it was real like,
like going through it and
then about to go on stage.
And I was like,
are you fucking kidding me?
None of that.
It's funny.
And Barry Katz is the whole
time as arguing behind me going,
he wants a law of Mike.
He wants a lav mic.
I go,
no,
I don't.
I want to fuck a microphone in my hand.
He wants a fogging law of mine.
Get a Mike.
I think a bear.
I don't want a lot of
Mike Bell Bell anymore.
I'll lob mine.
And he kept
telling me,
I got very cats.
Your manager I want to hit
at the time he was fired.
Him Too.
That's weird.
I fired him in an Alabama
and you guys are fired.
Him La Chapelle.
Yeah.
Did He,
was he your a manager at one point?
Did he owe you money or something?
Yes.
Yeah,
he owed me from money for a long time.
He was,
uh,
it was,
he owned a company that was called,
um,
Boston and New York comedy
or comedy in New York.
Comedy in New York.
Entertainment.
They,
they got in a hole and they started
owing people money from a college gigs,
but he paid me eventually,
but it took a while.
I'm not a bad guy.
He's a,
he's,
I don't know if I would say that.
I'll say it.
He's not a bad guy.
I definitely am not going
to be my manager right now,
but everybody's fired him.
Who else?
Who else fired?
I'm thinking about the Anthony Clarke,
his list of being firing to
Paulo fucking Dave Chappelle.
Jay still has him.
Right.
Amazing.
Um,
does Dane still have him?
Nope.
No Dane fired him.
Whoa,
dude.
I tried Dane Cook fired yet.
Barry Katz.
Yeah.
Yeah,
we talked about it.
Joe,
we talked about and on a podcast ice
house when Dan came in to talk about,
was thinking about myself
at all.
I tend to blank out too.
When you start talking about Barry Katz,
I just go,
you know,
the,
uh,
what were we talking about?
Oh yeah.
So that was how I did my company's
infrastructure with Barry going,
he wants somewhere Olam.
Why is he,
why is he doing that?
I have no idea.
I go,
I get to the fucking,
I tell him a hundred times,
just decides that you'd be
better off with a lot of light.
Looks better than a lot of
you should've worn a suit.
I love your impersonation.
I actually do.
I actually do a better impression.
I do it a really great,
very impression.
Uh,
if,
if you know Barry,
I do a great one,
like if you've worked with
Barry because like Brian,
so you be me.
Okay.
All right.
Fuck off.
So wait,
this is exactly how real Barry works.
Okay.
So Brian,
tell me about your podcast.
Okay.
No.
What'd you do on Brian?
That's crazy.
No,
no,
no.
The point is he,
he listens and he never speaks.
So you end up telling him more than
you'd ever want to tell anybody.
So he go,
he just nods like,
okay,
well you know,
you need to turn that shit back on him.
I never,
I was a child.
I was fucking fill,
fill the air form.
Just stare at them.
You didn't give me the best
of the best fucking advice.
He's given me the best,
uh,
pump up speeches and the best advices
in my life that I'd never took off with
that being the best advice he ever gave.
The first development deal I got was I
was doing comedy six months and he was
like,
can I give you some advice Paul?
And I was like,
yeah.
He goes,
hold on for a second.
And then he just goes,
disappears in his office.
It comes back and he's like,
give him get information.
Don't give it.
I'm gonna go,
what's that mean?
He goes,
exactly and hangs up.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
And basically saying the managers
and handle things mysterious.
I'm direct.
And that he basically was saying,
do not tell anyone you've
got a development deal.
It's just,
listen,
you don't wish I did that.
I wish I'd done that because I made a
bunch of enemies like starting in comedy
because I was like,
I was trying to fix to six
periods of underwhelm a deal.
And everyone's like,
but you work the door.
And I was like,
I know where that crazy
and no one was like,
congratulations.
Everyone's like,
fuck this guy.
So I wish I'd listened to him,
but I didn't,
I'm not a given get information,
give gum would give
information kind of guy.
You know what I mean?
I'm pretty,
I jumped to fight.
Why did you fire him?
Because,
um,
he didn't get me,
he didn't get my sense of humor.
Yeah.
Like I gave up,
I did a prank call.
He got purchased by
new wave entertainment.
I did a prank called a new wave one time
when I just called in and it was there
like voicemail for the
entire 500 people person,
company.
Right.
And I went and I was like,
and it was like,
well,
if you leave a message in the general
mailbox and I hit that and then I go,
barrier,
it's bird.
I'm fucked up.
Pick me up there.
I know you're listening
to this pig of the phone.
Very forgot the fucking phone.
Barry.
Brian,
I know you're there in your underwear.
Grab it.
Brian Volk wastes Brian,
grab it,
grab it.
And then Barry got really upset.
He was like,
dude,
you,
you can't do that Papa.
I mean there are fucking
adults don't work here.
And I was like,
wow.
I goes to joke Barry,
I'm a fucking comic.
You've got to get that.
And he was like,
if not a joke,
you were hammered.
And I was like,
no.
It was a fucking joke.
Like I do.
I really think you're sitting by a voice,
like a real answering machine at new wave.
Like I got so upset as
he and a guy at all.
Uh,
no,
but he has no,
no.
I don't think he is.
I don't think he drinks.
He tell you.
I know he against drinking
cause he liked the Tempe Improv.
He is not,
he's not going to work.
I would definitely say
he's not for drinking.
Was never for my drinking.
He was like mad.
His wedding.
I was hammered and shirtless.
I was sitting with Bobcat,
with a bobcat.
Jeff Ross,
um,
John Dimaggio.
You remember him?
John Measure Red Italian around guy and
like and like and like that table that,
where the fuck is that guy dude,
he's still around these fucking oh,
he's fucking awesome.
Yeah,
I run into him so much.
So John,
imagine you and I.
Oh man.
Buries wedding was the best
because everyone was fucked
up except for Barry and
Barry was trying to
micromanage everything.
So like he and he had all he had was
just a bunch of fucking stone talent.
So me,
Jeff Ross and John Dimaggio go
behind the stage to smoke a joint.
We all get spoken joint and
then John Dimaggio goes,
don't worry,
I know how to get in here.
And he just opens a curtain to get us
to the ballroom where everyone's having
the ceremony.
Opens a curtain.
Me,
Jeff,
Ross and him walk out and we're on stage
with his with like Barry's grandmother
reading a note and it was like,
oh,
we're high as fuck.
So then we all go sit down and fucking
and fucking bugging everyone starts.
Everyone starts like
giving like personal notes.
Right.
I'm sitting next to,
I want to say,
I want to say it's either Bob Katter,
Jeff Ross,
and so I'm fucking hammered.
I'm like,
right,
I'm hammered and everyone's going
up and saying special words.
Frank Caliendo came up and did like,
like six impressions in three minutes
and like why I dunno is three minutes of
thunder.
He went and did it and like every
comics coming up know it's fucking,
but it was actually to be
some time at cal ended.
Very talented.
So people are going up,
people are going up and really did.
I would have loved to done
five minutes at your wedding.
It was a fun,
it was a fun,
it was a fun wedding.
If you were not buried
Buddy Hackett's there.
Right?
This is gift.
Even better.
This gets even fucking better.
Okay,
so a buddy,
so everyone's going up and saying,
where's John?
Dimaggio goes up and says words.
Jeff Ross goes up and says words.
I think I want to say bobcat did.
I doubt he did though.
Knowing who he is.
I'm sitting in between him and Bobcat
and Jeff and one of them starts going,
you should talk.
And I was like,
what?
And like get on stage saying
it's like then total dick move,
right.
I should not be speaking at all.
Right.
Talk,
see something.
So I get up on stage,
grabbed the Mike,
Right when they start playing
the voicemails from Australia,
from his wife's family who can't be there.
Oh.
So I just talk over all,
oh,
it's really good to be here.
And they're like,
can may miss your Susana.
It was fucking nightmare.
Right?
And you kept talking because I didn't,
I'm so fucked up.
I couldn't hear a thing.
Right.
So the fucking,
I get off stage,
I got offstage,
Buddy Hackett gets on right after me.
They're still playing fucking voicemails,
right?
Buddy Hackett gets on.
He's more fucked up than I am.
And there's a fucking,
there's a piano that's humming going
and Buddy Hackett and typical buddy
Hackett voice goes time to fucking piano
off.
And they're like,
and everyone laughs and he goes,
I'm being fucking serious
trying to fucking piano.
Often though,
everyone asks him harder.
He goes,
daughter or I'll fix it and
everyone laughed even harder.
He throws his drink on the piano,
right?
Electric Piano,
it,
it goes.
This is like,
we see sparks smoke comes out and the
place falls on the ground laughing,
right?
Buddy had goes.
That's what I'm talking about.
Everyone applauds.
It is awesome here through a funny task
rank on an electric piano and Barry had
to pay like 25 grand
for the fucking piano.
So at the end of the wedding,
berries like a fucking worst
cavalcade up to shit on shit on shit.
Who's was a great wedding?
I would.
How much do you have to pay for the piano?
I don't know.
I'm finding the way I tell the story.
25 grand,
but quite five grand.
It was a beetle
romance story,
Buddy Hackett.
It's a bad ass.
And you fucked with him Joe.
I didn't
even respond to him.
He's a gangster.
I didn't respond to all the time.
You fucked with the gangs.
I guess I did.
He's a,
apparently it was a very angry dude.
Yeah,
he was.
He was.
He was a nice guy other
than met buddy a few times.
I liked him a lot.
I was on season of comics.
I watched it on my couch jam.
Fascinating.
It was like really?
This guy was clearly steel in
material calcs was like yelling at me.
You're a fucking asshole.
When I was like,
wow,
you handled it like a gentleman.
He was a guy who stole jokes.
That's the guy was still jokes for sure.
We got my guy responds like that.
Exactly.
That's how they did it.
But when a guy responds like that,
there's only one reason,
man.
I mean,
psychologically speaking,
why would you be so adamant about the
idea that you know that this guy wasn't a
thief and that you know,
you never heard those jokes for like,
what are you saying like you and then
the other check that was there was like,
he made him his own.
He made those jokes his on and I was like,
wow.
It was Monique.
She was like me.
Yeah,
you made those jokes you're on.
And I was like,
whoa.
I was like,
you made them your own wow.
Areas.
Last comic standing was
not the yardstick for us.
And by the way,
by the way,
the judging,
this was a very cats show too.
And by the way,
the judging was complete total horse shit.
It didn't matter.
We,
there was people that we voted for that
didn't get in and people that we didn't
go for the God in,
they had decided,
the producers all got
together and decided how to,
how to put people on.
I remember I did trying to remember,
I'm drew Carey walked off.
It was a judge and uh,
who else didn't matter
because of Dan Adelman.
10 elements are very funny
comic and he should've won,
but he just wasn't castable like,
it wasn't one of the guys that are
looking for that's so ridiculous.
Them ideas of who's
castable and who's not.
You know,
it's so funny whenever
you get a bunch of people,
like I'm so used to doing the podcast
where there's no one telling us what to
do,
but to watch like Dave Attell doing
showed yesterday and the guy's like,
can you sit up?
Can you move this?
The guy asked me,
actually asked me,
can you,
can you push your right
pant leg down a little?
And I was like,
why?
Well,
it's kind of puffy in that one spot.
I'm like,
oh my fucking God.
They,
you go fucking what kind
of Weirdo micro managing.
You're looking at puffs on pants,
but that's how they do it,
man.
What you want to show.
Yeah,
exactly.
It is their job.
When we were in a showing,
it's like five,
six different people yelling instructions
and all trying to piece this thing
together.
It's way less harmonious.
Then you piecing it together on your own,
you know,
the less,
less is more,
you know,
like,
do you feel like that with your show?
Do you ever feel like
with birth to conquer,
like man,
I should take the reins on this bitch
and just figured out how to do it myself.
Aye.
Uh,
did he ever feel like that?
I do.
I do,
but I feel like I would fuck it up.
And I don't know if I
could say this forever,
but we'll definitely
do this for right now.
The people I'm working with right now,
and I know I'm not talking
to my mall brush company,
just talking about
executive wise executives,
the ones I'm working with really seem
like they know what they're doing.
Yeah,
you have a good crew like that.
You actually fucking
really good crew and so,
so what they're doing now,
and we're,
and I'm not doing birth conquer anymore,
I'm doing a different show.
What are you doing now?
It's called trip flip.
Chip.
Awesome.
Yeah,
that's a good idea.
Great.
It's a fucking,
what is it?
It's a great show.
We go and we've fucking
take people on vacation,
like a fucking ridiculous vacation.
We showed them how to vacation,
like we tell them we don't like,
we go to like the mall of
America or we'll find him there.
We go to the mall of America and we go,
who wants to go to Mexico?
And people go,
I do.
And to go,
great.
I'll show you what to do in Mexico.
I'm taking the Cabo and I'm not going
to make you go stay at the resort.
I'm going to take you on.
I'm gonna show you real
cool shit to do in Cabo.
So as a viewer you watch it and you go,
shut up.
I can go fucking Baja racing.
Like I can do that for the day.
I can ride camels on the
beach to a tequila tasting.
Like there's like we show you the
coolest shit to do in the cities.
Most ideal fucking job ever phone.
You get the best vacations every,
we weren't going to show we
were in Cancun and drive him,
uh,
Lamborghini's,
Ferrari's and Mercedes hundred 40 miles
an hour on open fucking roads because we
found,
and,
and you'll find it too when you watch it,
the company that has paid off the federal
Raleigh's to let them fucking drive
these cars 140 miles on open roads.
Whoa.
Yeah,
it's too,
it's Mexico.
I mean that's the way it works.
They teach you on the track.
You got to run a track for the like
half the day and then they take,
take,
take you out to tilt in such a loom
and you can just air these bitches out.
Have you seen that video online
or the guy in the Mercedes or a a
neighbor?
He goes sideways around a corner.
Do you think that's a,
do you think that's a fake video?
Like A,
and I think it's a fake video.
I can't be really,
well I think it's very,
because it's one of those videos.
It's like one,
why is it guy just,
I don't know.
Recording people do that.
I know.
And then it's just like how shit and
he was barely going fast and he loses
control.
Did you notice that?
Like he just,
he wasn't going like super fast.
He just like kind of
sped up and I was like,
how did he lose control of
his Lamborghini that bad?
And then when,
how it was placed in
between the two cards,
it's like,
all right,
this is some kind of weird fake video.
Like who's behind it though?
Who knows?
Like Lamborghini maybe would say
you probably got a good point,
but Lamborghinis
are notoriously hard to control and
that's a four wheel drive car too.
That's a funky car.
Really hard to control that.
Especially because it's all
like Salish paddle battle.
I might not be,
see that's,
that's the,
that's the Guyardo the one that crashed.
Right,
and the Guy Auto Yuki,
you can still get them with the manual.
The Guy,
you know,
he might've like over hit the gas on a
shift or he might've went sideways and
not sure.
I'll have some and he might've
had to rig it might be real,
but I agree with you.
It doesn't look weird.
It's,
it's a suspicious physics.
Right.
It's weird because I saw it last night
for my first time and immediately I
looked at it going,
how did he just lose
control that fastest that I,
it wasn't that fast.
He wasn't going that fast.
Well,
it doesn't matter anyway,
when you're going around a corner,
especially
using street tires,
but the car gets out of control.
There's no fucking bring it a pack.
It's hard.
You just,
you have to know how to drive.
There's a great video of two guys in
Corvettes and there's a guy behind him and
films it and they're in sugar land,
not in sugar land.
The woodlands,
I think in Texas,
one of those.
And they take off at the light.
One Guy fucking completely
loses control t bones,
you know,
car like the fun of it.
And it's,
it's a real video that's super real
because the guy and the guy and they've
watched the video.
All right,
let's see what these assholes do.
You know they're going to race.
Yeah.
And he got it.
He,
that guy is going to be
filming everything from now on.
What a great to catch on film.
And here's another thing to always think
about when you look at these videos,
it's like you didn't know
that majority of people,
you know,
like I'm a little different.
If I were to have filmed it,
it would be looked different.
But the majority of people,
you know when you're,
you're in a car,
you're filming,
use your iPhone,
your steering,
you're doing all this shit when
you're going around a corner.
He was really good with making sure he
caught every single thing that happened
while he's driving and filming.
And it was just too good of like,
okay,
yeah,
you got the money shot,
where in reality it was probably like
this phone would be flopping around
looking at fucking ceilings and shit.
You know,
a very good point.
It's like you kind of forget that.
Yes,
it's filmed on a shitty camera.
I,
it looks realistic,
but the money shot was recorded perfectly.
Everything was recorded a
little bit too perfectly.
And as somebody that
does that kind of shit,
it's,
it's kind of like a,
I know what the reality is that
this is just some guy filming it.
He would have been filming
his girlfriend's Crotch,
you know,
like,
it would've been just like,
yeah,
maybe if that had been you,
you have gotten the shot perfectly.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
The month.
There's a lot of use out there.
Yeah.
You got to realize this guy
is a guy who's filming things,
you know,
but by just by having a guy who's like,
who knows,
who knows though,
but like it wasn't supposed to be
the guy driving there was filming.
I think it was,
I don't know.
I saw it last night.
So,
I don't even remember,
but some guy showed it to
me at the show last night.
Yeah.
There's a lot of Douche bags
out there driving like that.
Yeah.
There's a lot of cars out there that are
super powerful and they're getting more
powerful every year.
That's what's really nuts.
Every time like Lamborghini
has to put in new car out,
they're going to make it more powerful.
You know,
last year it was 500
horsepower,
$200,000 was the car I was driving cheese.
I mean you can,
like I,
I try to explain to the people
who were driving it with,
they were younger.
I was like,
this is a once in a lifetime experience
that this will never happen again.
And they at that age become a super
baller and start buying up them bitches.
What kind of car was it
that you were driving?
Uh,
the fucking $600,000 one.
It's a Lamborghini Mercia Lago or,
and then tour Aventador
we did vintage doors.
The new one had the pedal,
the pedal shifters sound.
Those things make her demons.
I heard you.
And I want to say that by Osmosis.
You know,
like by listening to you enough.
I don't know if you've
said this about cars,
but I did say this on TV and I definitely,
I could hear you in my head saying it.
The car barked at you.
Yeah.
A lot of people say that just
like they would fucking like,
and I could hear it barking
at me and I fucking loved it.
I love to hear it.
Here's a manly sounding cars.
Ah,
Lamborghinis and Ferraris and some of the
sweetest tones like the exhaust tones.
God Man.
Yeah.
People,
there's like videos on
youtube where people just have
Lamborghini exhaust notes.
It's got that crazy,
I think they have like some
of them are [inaudible],
right.
This is the mercy of [inaudible] 12
I'm a horrible host cause I don't,
all I know is that it barked
at me fucking Beasley cars,
but there's some Michael
Vick dog in between my legs.
It's like,
why would you,
what are you doing with that
crazy thing really in the states,
in the states,
what are you doing?
Because you can't drive it
over a hundred thousand,
a hundred miles,
a hundred miles per hour.
Like he'll go to jail over a hundred
miles an hour when you really Yo.
And yeah,
that's what they were saying.
The guy that started the company and uh,
and,
and catechumens saying,
I had all these cars,
but I was in the states
and I couldn't use them.
And I came down to Mexico
once and some guy said,
you know,
you have a pair of for federal alleys,
you can drive whatever you want.
Why did he have all of these cars?
Because he was rich.
Wow.
And so he,
now he has a business as a business.
He decided to take all his cars
that he wasn't into or not driving,
sending to Cancun,
pay a federal Raleigh's and you
can just take them out for the day.
I mean,
you got to go with like,
you've got to go in a group.
You can't just,
it's not like you just
get a Lamborghini to air,
but it's fucking fun.
I've never driven anything
140 miles an hour race.
Racing cars is fun.
It's gotta be very addictive.
Fucking dude.
All the shit get your body to go fast and
it's supposed to because you feel that
g forces when you're going
around corners and you make up,
we were going around
corners at 70 miles an hour.
That's fucking seven like
put that in perspective.
What you do want to interstate.
I was taking corners at that Shit
and you make your real face like you,
there's no cool face when
you drive a car that fast.
Do you make your real face like that?
That like I did this like eh cause
that's what I do when I do that speed.
Did you feel the rear end
sliding on you at all?
Yeah,
because it was raining.
Oh
it was raining.
You have to be careful of a,
with a car that's got that much
power to when you on the gas,
you know like,
like,
like that stupid car
that I have that Shelby,
the Mustang I,
every time I hit second gear I can't,
you got to make sure you don't stomp
on the gas too much because it will get
sideways on you in second gear.
Give you a little more.
Yeah,
for Christ you can drive this car.
I doubt that.
You know that the odds that
that guy in that video,
you know if I can drag that.
Oh you say that though.
But some,
a lot of people buy cars and they don't
necessarily know how to handle them when
though the asset and goes out on them.
I would not be able to recover that car.
It's hard man.
It's hard and sometimes you don't want
to let go of the steering or you don't
want to let go of the gas either.
Sometimes you have to,
you have to power oversteer you have to,
you have to fight it with the throttle.
You know you have to keep
your foot on the gas.
Cause if you,
if it snaps back and be like
catches Griff and then you know,
while you're already
in a turn like you can,
you can get fucked.
Oh we drove.
It depends entirely on a car to those
cars are meant to be driven like that.
Like Porsche's are notorious for like,
they have a weird weight bias cause
they were like an engine in the rear.
So like when you're going around corners,
like sideways,
you're dealing with the physics
of this engine hanging out back.
It's like 60% of the weight
is the ass end of the car.
So,
you know,
so if you had a friend who
came to you and was like,
man,
I just got my big deal.
Oh I need some,
I want to buy a car.
So the one car would you get with it?
It depends on what kind
of a person he was.
A single dude.
Yeah.
But is he,
is he an animal?
Is the,
uh,
it has to be a calm fellow that you know,
likes is comfortable car?
No,
he's,
you know who he is.
He's a Dane Cook because I'm never
forget the conversation you over Dane,
when Dana talked about his Maserati,
that was a lemon.
I'll never forget that because
I'm the kid wasn't a Maserati.
I think it was a Bentley.
No.
Uh,
uh,
Aston Martin.
Martin.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So like,
like if you could go back in time and
give Dayna Carter pickup to buy for like,
Hey man,
this is your first,
like this is a treat.
If you want to really well engineered car,
you can't go wrong with a Porsche.
They're just so well engineered.
It's up to your first Porsche that
you had that that was a hunk of shit.
Yeah,
it was a 411-NINE-ONE-1941.
It was called a nine nine six,
nine nine six six.
It wasn't a six one one where he just
called ATNT want to find out what you owe.
But yeah,
that I had one car that had five problems
with it in two years before I got rid
of it after a major problem.
We had the best car after that.
I wish you still had that accurate NSX.
Yeah.
That was like a fucking matchbox
car and I was so dope car.
They're coming out with a new one,
you know,
accurate is ready to make a new a NSX.
I think it comes out in 2013 but they,
uh,
had it in the Avengers.
Remember the car it gets in.
That's the,
that was a prototype.
Yeah.
I know that shit.
Our Jaguar or Jaguars a girl cars,
because I saw a Jaguar convertible the
other day and a girl was driving and I
was like,
damn,
that's so beautiful that God does it
have to be girl Jaguars are awesome,
beautiful Jaguar.
There's super powerful to the new ones.
They have these uh,
x k asses.
I think it is.
They,
they have like some
Beasley fucking cars now.
They're great cars,
man.
Fuck yeah.
Yeah.
I would tell most for most people I
would say just get a well engineered car.
Just don't really want a race car and
anything with the best fucking car around
right now is in my opinion,
dead serious.
Like for the money be a,
what's the genesis the other day?
Oh,
the one that looks like a Mercedes
car.
Hondai it puts out Hyundai Hondai
puts out a great fucking car.
Well,
especially this one,
this one.
They've basically taken all the design
elements of Mercedes and Alexis.
They're like best costs essentially
made the same kind of car.
It's real fucking similar.
And they do a,
it's a great car.
I mean it looks like a Mercedes.
It looks like a Mercedes.
All the shit in Mercedes.
God,
it just doesn't have the like whatever
the thing that makes it a Mercedes is
$90,000.
Well it's,
it's very high end.
They said,
they said it's very comfortable to drive
and they're really reliable cars too.
You know the thing about Hyundai
is it's not like it's a shit car.
They're,
they're reliable cars just as much.
So as a,
any other car that's in that price range,
but it's a pretty nice,
but like $34,000 a year
send to visually wise,
I don't think it's anything special.
Well neither is Alexis.
Look at the Lexus ls
four 60 I think it is,
the new one,
whatever it is.
Beautiful car.
But real set date,
it's all about luxury is transportation
and those cars like Alexis,
those cars are so quiet and peaceful.
I love,
it's like,
yeah,
if you're into that man,
I'd say get Alexis,
those,
Lexis,
those Lexus four doors.
I like the most relaxing,
calm,
they absorb bumps.
They,
they're not handling cars.
So the car,
you're going to go around a corner on
the gas and get a fucking good feeling in
your balls.
I fucking on that care
about Gary Valentine.
When we were working together on the expo,
had a green Lexus and his
whole thing was it Joe,
you did it with a member and he had a
green Lexus and his whole thing was how
silent it was.
Yeah,
we got the car one time,
remembers it,
a country club called Robinson ranch.
Me,
Gary and I think it was
brother and a few other people.
So what time we getting validated?
We get into the car and he just
shuts the door and it looks at me.
He goes,
backi how fucking quiet as this car.
It was pretty quiet.
And he goes,
it's pretty fun.
Quiet,
right?
And I go,
yeah.
And he goes,
put it in drive.
It's not fucking totally drunk.
Fucking Gary Valentine.
I missed that mother fucker.
He do you remember Mike Burton?
Burton,
Mike Burton.
Where would I remember Mike Burton,
a comic from La,
hung around the comedy
comedy at the Improv.
Krav Maga.
But I'm Mike Burden.
This is my favorite Gary Valentine story.
I fucking it.
And I know that the mean
kind of Gary on one time.
Well love to God.
He's fucking funny.
So one time decide where we do the
show.
We wrap on Thursday and we decide we go
to for most of that drinks and I said to
Gary,
I go,
we should go to Vegas.
And he was like,
let's do it.
And uh,
we look at Mike Burden and
a and which one's that?
That's my partner.
Yeah,
you don't mind.
So,
so we go to him and Scott Henry and go,
let's go to fucking Vegas.
And Mike Bergner's isn't
that I don't want to go.
I want to come on Burton go.
And he's like,
ah,
I don't want to go and carry goes,
fuck you.
This is the problem to you.
You need to go.
And he's like,
ah,
I don't want to go.
I got a spot at the Hollywood improv.
Fuck the Hollywood improv.
So here he goes,
fuck it.
You guys work on Burton?
I'm going to go back to Santa Monica.
He's living with Kevin.
At the time.
I'm gonna go back to Santa
Monica and get my shit.
I'll meet you at Burton and Henry's house.
Let me go.
Perfect.
So we go and I'm awake.
Some Scott Henry's house,
we decide,
we convince Burton and Burton goes,
man,
I fucking,
I'll go and I go,
burden is a great idea.
Why don't you hang out in the back of my
truck hide and we'll tell big Gary that
you're not going.
And then we'll get on the interstate
will surprise him and be like,
Gary,
look,
he's coming because Gary's not witness.
He's back in the shit.
Burton goes,
that's great.
So we packed all our shit.
We got out of Burton and Henry's house.
Burton gets in the way back at the truck,
like back with the beers are,
I had an expedition at the time and he
hides back there and we wait for like 15
minutes and all of a sudden
Gary Valentine shows up.
He shows up,
he's got his bags,
he's holding his hands.
He opens the backseat door
like the middle opens,
hops in.
He goes,
where's Burton?
And we're like,
he didn't come and he
shuts the door and he goes,
let me tell you what's wrong
with that motherfucker.
And we're like,
uh,
and then he goes,
and I'll tell you why you shouldn't be
a comic anymore cause he's not fucking
funny.
And as we drive,
we're pulling out and I see,
I see Mike Burton sit up in the weight
back and Gary talked for like 10 fucking
minutes,
just talk shit about.
And all of a sudden I go,
hey Gary,
would you mind passing
me a beer into the back?
And he turns around and he goes,
Hey Burton.
Then turns back to us.
He goes,
when we get to fucking tell me,
we were like,
oh,
there was never a good time.
It was the fucking most sane.
Oh God,
I'll never,
and they talked,
me and Scott Henry Sat in the front,
Gary Valentine and Mike Burton sign in
the back and talked like hashed it out.
Like,
how do you hash that out?
Yeah,
right.
I think Bert,
I don't know,
burden the burden.
I think he's teaching Krav Maga now.
Yeah.
Yes.
The guy's done training centers now.
He's a really smart dude.
Comedy's not fair.
Everybody fucks
Krav Maga is Jewish,
right?
Yes.
Is there is really a sort of system of
self defense based on a lot of different
marsh slapping,
right?
It's Jewish slapping.
No,
no,
no.
Let me just whittle it down
to what I heard it was okay.
Is Jewish bitch slapping?
Yeah,
that's what I heard from some new Jeremy.
No crop of guys like Oh fuck from
a guy that listens to this podcast.
It's at my daughter's dance class.
He told you was slapping.
No Fuck nevermind.
I wish I hadn't said this.
Yeah,
don't settle down birds.
No crop.
The guy's legit legit
form of self defense.
I might mostly,
you know
like um,
you know it's like street stuff like
show you a correct that vacations of
techniques and self defense situations
as opposed to like just doing Jujitsu or
just doing kickboxing or
something along those lines.
It's more applicable to
like getting attacked.
It's,
but it's all the basic
techniques of a all,
you know,
all the effective martial arts.
You know,
they,
they go over choke,
hold to go over arm locks,
they go over,
you know,
all sorts of different,
it's not just,
you know,
a self defense.
They,
they,
they incorporate a lot
of different things.
It's like a system of,
you know,
taking like what's the most useful
martial arts in a real life situation.
So that's what it is,
which is,
you know,
there's room for that.
I'm,
I'm personally of the school that,
you know,
like people say,
well we,
like,
I,
I've had these arguments with the so
called Lake Street defense people and
they're like,
well,
we learn is a,
how to defend yourself on the street.
You know,
it was a no rules on the street.
And in the,
the mixed martial arts Dojo,
you know,
there's rules and that's
all well and good.
We appreciate the discipline,
but there's no rules,
there's no rules on the street.
So that's why I support is different.
You know,
something,
I like to try to bite you and grab
your balls or something like that.
But my,
my take has always been that the most
effective techniques aren't the techniques
that work on people who don't know what
they're doing and all the techniques,
almost all of them.
And that you see in so-called
self defense courses,
they only work if people
don't know what they're doing.
Like the all the grabbing
hands and pulling in you,
you ain't grab my hand bench.
You know,
I'm,
I'm going to be a wild cat.
We've got,
we've got some crazy shit going on right
here and you're not grabbing me and
just holding on to me.
That's nonsense.
And so when,
when I see any of that
self defense nonsense,
I go,
there's a reason why this doesn't work.
And the reason why it doesn't work,
it's because it doesn't work on a killer.
You need to,
everything you need to do.
And if you wanted to
learn true martial arts,
you should learn what works on killers.
Learn what works on the
best fighters on the planet.
Learn what works on Moitai finders.
Learn what works on a Jujitsu fighter is
learn what works on a guy who knows how
to fuck people up and he's
been training in it for years.
You learn how to deal with that guy.
Don't learn how to deal with some dude
like pulling out your keys and going for
his eyes.
Cause most likely he'll knock you the
fuck out before you get close enough to do
that.
Learn how to do what works on killers.
That's my opinion.
So I don't,
I'm not a big believer
in self defense courses.
I'm a big believer in martial arts.
I think you,
if you want to learn Jujitsu,
you should learn the type of Jujitsu
where you know if you get ahold of someone
it doesn't matter.
That's it.
You,
you own them now.
That's your world and you
strangled them and you,
you get to that point and that's a,
that's a beautiful tool
to have in your toolbox.
It's a beautiful thing to,
to,
to be in possession of.
Marshall childs was saying that you
don't ever get that if you're in a self
defense course because first of all,
you're not going to have the amount of uh,
proficiency and doing these techniques
like knee brakes and attacks to the
ground cause you're not really doing them
full blast and training against people
who were resisting.
So a lot of what you're doing,
you're drilling repetition and you
might get better at completing those
movements,
but the odds of doing it on
a guy who knows how to fight,
it's pretty fucking small.
Yeah.
Anderson Silva type dude,
knock your fucking dome off
your neck and it's that simple.
You know,
you're never going to get to eye
gouge him is going to light you up.
And it's like you've got
to look at it that way.
I,
in my opinion.
And so there's nothing
wrong with crop them.
God,
it's a good way to work out.
It's a good way to train,
you know,
and it's a very effective
system in martial arts.
Do you mean you worked with Marshall
at the laugh laughing school?
Uh Huh.
Yeah,
he does.
He did.
He talk to you about more a Jujitsu?
No,
he does Jiu Jitsu.
Yeah,
like aggressive.
We talked a little bit about it,
but he's,
he's definitely,
uh,
he said that exact same thing,
that it just was like a nice set of,
um,
abilities to have in place and that he
get became more relaxed around people.
He never,
because he was smaller,
not smaller but smaller,
and he just never felt like he could
ever get hurt because he knew how to get
out of it.
Well,
you know,
you can still get hurt.
You got to always be
careful.
People,
this is the,
first of all,
there's knives and guns and
gangs and sticks and you know,
you can always get hurt.
Like the idea that you were in vulnerable
now and you can just walk through any
bad neighborhood is crazy,
you know?
But the less,
you certainly have less apprehensions
because you know that you've reached a
physical proficiency when it comes to
defending yourself that very few people
have ever reached.
So if some shit goes down,
most likely you're going to be fine.
Most likely,
this guy's in for some horrible,
rude awakening,
which most people don't
know how to fight her into.
If they,
if they get in there with a
guy who knows how to fight,
they're in for a terrifying awakening
of what's the difference between,
so I want to spend zero time training
out of fine and someone has dedicated a
lifetime of doing it as a different
[inaudible] guys going to own you.
And it's a terrifying feeling
to get owned by someone,
especially if you get
on in the straight man.
Whew.
Especially if you get onto to the street
and you're the one that started it.
Oh,
it's like that video.
That dude,
oh,
the two kids where it's like a Mexican
kid with his socks pulled up to his knees
and there's some white kid
in jeans and they're like,
come on.
And then the white,
the white kid clearly knows
like some sort of Asian defense,
like starts doing steps and
kicking practice kick in.
And the guy was like,
no,
no street fight street fight only.
And it was like,
no,
this is what I'm doing.
And he's like,
no,
no man.
I ain't doing that kind of shit.
No funky vice,
just regular fights.
It's all mine is on my,
it's one of my favorite fights I've
favorited and all that youtube page,
like I favorited it that I'm fucking one
of the first people to discover Kimbo
slice.
You know the beautiful
thing about being around
people know how to fight isn't
very rarely getting flights.
It's most people know how to
fight our fucking pretty calm.
They'd get all that shit out in the gym.
You know,
you can get all that shit out
in a controlled environment.
We have a desire for conflict.
We have a desire to
fucking old come things,
fuck the car.
There's a desire of that,
that all that shit can
be erased in the gym.
And when you erase it to the gym,
you deal with yourself on an even playing
field instead of being overwhelmed by
road rage or overwhelmed by disappointment
in your own personal life and
existence and whatever's frustrations
that have been building inside of you,
percolating fucking up
your physical existence.
Because the moment you're in,
in any interaction,
you're acting unbalanced.
You know,
walking down the street on
the curb just staring at cars.
Yeah.
The Fuck's wrong with you?
That's the guy from yet last night,
what was he doing?
Saw Him walking on the curb,
just staring at cars and I was like,
he's probably crazy.
Chick was just walking on the,
on the sidewalk and I was like,
man,
maybe they're all mapped out.
Yeah.
You don't want to chicks getting
street fights with their dudes.
You got together and fuck
a throw down together.
Go home and fuck.
Does that happen?
I said,
Dina,
I didn't like a movie.
Right.
Streetfighter yeah,
something along those lines.
Right?
I don't know.
I can't imagine.
I've never been able to with a girl that
fought conversation went south hard.
How many smuggling you
never been around a girl.
What's up with that?
You haven't been around a
girl that likes to fight.
No shit ever.
Man.
Girls don't want to drag you into fights.
That's one of the scariest things.
You get everything on try.
I would imagine you would have attract
that when you were younger though.
Yeah,
a lot of them.
Yeah.
They want to stick.
You want people like a dog versus good
behind the scenes stories about you that
I fucking dying to talk
about behind the scenes.
Yeah.
Like just like,
just like,
uh,
yeah.
I don't know.
It's fucking not,
why did I say that?
Your ego does attic.
No,
no,
no.
But it has to do with violence.
It's almost nothing.
So nothing about violence.
It's about you being a friend
of Dan's like uh oh yeah,
let's not,
what if it's bad people don't
talk about about people.
Oh God damn.
I don't know why I'm fucking,
something's wrong.
My brain.
Something's wrong with Berg.
Bryan Bryan series.
What's wrong?
What happened with was your thing,
you can't smoke weed in
front of cameras anymore.
Yeah,
you can kind of be sneaky about it.
Okay.
It's stupid.
You stream has some sort of policy.
Yeah,
we have like vaporizer and still
have them while taking a hit.
Joe,
why do you yeah,
let's just wrap this bitch up.
Cause you know you guys came a little
late and I still have to look at that
property,
right.
We'll go with you pretending
where your investors,
that's,
I'm looking at that and find an allergist.
They inspect really bullshit stuff.
Let's do it.
But I don't know about the fault lines,
things that make you go.
So,
uh,
next week in the podcast we've got Shane
Smith Bassnectar and the great bobcat
Goldthwait should be very fun.
Yeah,
we'll have a great talk about Barry Katz.
Bob Has,
oh Harry,
since he was fucking a child,
he's known Berenson.
Susan bobcat lived in Barry's closet.
Is the story like very owned.
I had a closet that he rented out in a,
in uh,
I'm sure I'm raping this right.
Bob Barry rented out a closet in like
Boston University or Boston College.
Right.
And bobcat rented it when he was like 16.
Wow.
Yeah.
Bob.
Bob Cats don't bury for every
bobcat's another Boston comic.
People don't realize,
you know,
he made it on the big screen,
uh,
and made it sort of almost
as like a Hollywood guy.
But his origins are in
Boston too and as fuck.
Oh yeah.
He was bobcat's always
been fucking hilarious.
Ever hear the CD meet Bob met Bob and
it's like hamburger is made at with a
hamburger or something like that.
He's a,
yeah,
he's great.
He's,
Bob Bobcat Goldthwait like
with bobcat being a character.
It's really weird.
Like,
you know,
like that guy that's,
yeah.
I wonder if he feels weird about that.
But one,
if that's a word,
cause like Jj Walker,
like when he got older,
would hate when people would
like yell out dynamite.
They would hate it.
Hate it.
Cause he wasn't doing that anymore.
Now he's just a standup up trying to make
a living and apparently he didn't like
that when people,
that's what they say.
I never did it from,
maybe the guy loved it.
Maybe one asshole did it say dynamite.
Dynamite.
And he's like,
I don't like to do it.
But that would be weird though,
because I mean that's what kind
of got everyone to know who he is.
That's how,
but after like 10 years,
man can stop saying dynamite,
but an even worse than that.
Imagine being bobcat where you do the,
Oh yeah,
I worked with him.
He stopped doing that,
right?
Yeah.
Well he was doing,
um,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
Maybe it's like a goto thing with a joke.
Like subtly cause he's
still doing stand up.
Can you still do a stand up?
Of course.
Yeah.
Cause he didn't,
he stopped for a while and
he was directing Kimmel.
I mean you drugs Kimmel I think.
Yeah,
it was directing the man show.
He directed directed movie does well
and he did the world's worst dad,
which is a great fucking movie.
There's a scene that no,
but I want to [inaudible] movie that he's
got coming up in the American dream or
something like that.
I'll find out worlds worse.
Dad,
Robert will post American
plays a dad whose son,
guys from auto fixation erotica and he
writes him a suicide note and says he
killed himself,
is going to deal with it.
And because of the suicide note,
the kids' writings become popular.
Wow.
And the dad is doing all the writings
and the data was wanting to be a writer.
It's a great fucking movie.
It is a great fucking movie.
His name is called God bless America.
And it's,
it's very violent and it just,
so we played,
it looks awesome.
That'll be fun.
That'll be fun and reveal.
Drool on him.
Dude.
I just want to talk.
I'm going to get,
just like when I talk about
some things with Bobcat,
no past present,
future ex wife,
you know all those funds.
Don't do that Brian Thomas,
man.
No,
I'm just me not going to be a problem.
Just kidding.
Too late.
Thanks to everybody who tuned in this
week and thanks to everyone who came out
to the Ice House comedy club last night.
Fucking trying to show
seriously a really amazing,
we had a great,
great time.
It was so cool to be able to
do that on a Wednesday night.
Joe,
I don't know if we've
talked about this or not.
I'm thinking about like,
we should just take over Wednesday
from now on and stiff doing Friday.
Wednesday's when all the
comics are in town for,
we can do Fridays too.
Sometimes.
I like doing Fridays in the morale would
keep our Fridays open so we'll go up to
the off guard,
whatever bitch.
Um,
but either way we'll be doing
more shows to the ice house.
It's a great place.
And,
and I got to develop some
new material now before my,
uh,
special gifts.
Are you releasing your special online?
Yeah,
exactly.
Um,
they're building a website for it now.
It's going to take a couple of months.
So,
uh,
probably won't be until
like August or September.
Then I'll release it.
Let's go on a mushroom trip so we can
even get new material if you can handle
mushrooms anymore.
Yeah,
I can.
Okay.
All right.
We'll do,
it just has to be comfortable.
Like a comfortable situation.
It can be a hundred degrees in a
hotel room and you and me naked.
No,
no.
Wow.
I know this hotel that was like the chair.
Have a great story guys.
Let's go look at that property,
Joe.
Yes.
We're going to go do that.
We're going to look,
go look at desk squad west,
also known as higher primates studios.
Um,
thank you to everybody
tuned in for the podcast.
Thank you to the flashlight
for sponsoring our podcast.
And if you go to Joe rogan.net,
click on a link.
Can I get,
can I get entering the code name?
Rogan.
Get Yourself 15% off the number one sex
toy from and the shirt that Brian is
displaying and his image
is the machine shirt.
Oh,
I am the machine.
The Bird Christ your shirt
and you can get that at Bert.
Bert,
bert.com hollow support your
boy baby needs new shoes.
Come on.
Seven.
Um,
uh,
and you can also a bro.
When are you going to,
you're doing a podcast soon now.
I started taping it on the road with
my bumping bodyguards with your body
guards.
I've been getting bodyguards ever went.
So I've been doing podcasts with them
cause you go for your TV show crazy
places.
We get bodyguards by,
I don't know when it's coming out.
It's coming out.
When I get,
when I get a little time under my belt,
I've got to also,
I'm some fucking 75 pages
due by August 1st my book.
So I'm a little overwhelmed.
So I have,
I appreciate everyone that emails
me and says start your podcast.
I'm working on it.
I'm working on everything.
Okay.
Her crusher,
you're a fucking savage.
God bless Ya.
A couple of few jail.
That's it.
You fucking dirty freaks.
We'll see you next week.
Thank you for everything.
We appreciate it all.
Thanks to ana.com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain,
new mood,
shroom tech sport,
shroom tech,
[inaudible].
And uh,
next week we're going to launch the kettle
bells and let you know what the fuck
is up.
We're ironing out all the
details right now and um,
uh,
that's it.
So you see guys and a good bye for now.
Yeah.